GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO OUR
ASSEMBLY --
BLUE RIBBON.
COMMISSION ON EARLY EDUCATION WE
ARE AT THE AT THE FINAL HEARING
THIS MORNING IT SO WE'RE EXCITED --
TO TO SEE ALL THAT THE FACES
HERE TO JOIN US TODAY AND UNVEIL
OUR OUR OUR PRODUCT HERE TODAY
THIS IS ALMOST THE FINAL THE
FINAL STAGE BUT THIS IS THE
FINAL PUBLIC HEARING.
SO THIS OF COURSE IS THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ON EARLY CHATTERJEE EDUCATION AS
IT JUST SOME CONTEXT WE'VE HAD A
FEW.
GOOD YEARS REINVESTING IN THE
BUDGET FOR EASY WE KNOW DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION ARE YOU SEE
PROGRAMS WERE CUT BY ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH AS SPEAKER
NOTICE.
SOME AS A REASON WHY OFFICE AND
SO WE HAD A REALLY TOUGH PERIOD --
EARLIER THIS DECADE FOR EASY
PROGRAMS WE START TO TO RE
INVEST IN OUR EASY PROGRAMS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO BUT THE
AFTER THE SECOND YEAR OF DOING
THAT -- THE
SPEAKER AND OUR ASSEMBLY --
BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT TEAM ASIDE
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S NICE THAT WE
ARE PUTTING MONEY BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR WE NEED TO TAKE A BIG
PICTURE AS FAR AS WHERE WE'VE
BEEN WHERE WE ARE TODAY THE WAY
YOU WANT TO GO IN THE FUTURE IS
LOOKING AT A HOLISTIC
PERSPECTIVE.
AS FAR AS WHAT'S NEEDED AS FAR
AS HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
FOUND THAT.
FAMILIES CAN --
AND ROLL THESE PROGRAMS THEY
COULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE HOURS
WHICH FIT THEN.
MAKE SURE THAT PROGRAMS ARE
VIABLE --
JUST LAST WEEK WE HEARD THAT ARE
SACRAMENTO CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAD.
TO SHUT DOWN SOME OF THEIR PRE
K. PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE PROPER RE INVESTMENTS AS
FAR AS THE RATES --
PROPER INVESTMENTS IN THE RATES
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE ISSUES AS WELL --
MAKING SURE WE FOCUS ON NOT JUST
THE SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM BUT
THAT FAMILY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
THAT.
THE THE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY SIR
THE COMMISSION HELD THANKS OVER
THE TWO YEAR PERIOD THROUGH ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND IN PLACES LIKE PALM DESERT
LONG BEACH FRESNO SOUTH LA
OAKLAND.
IN TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE --
POLICY FOCUSED FOCUSING ON THE
OUTCOME OF THOSE RESPONSES IN
THOSE IN THOSE --
AND THOSE FINDINGS AND WE WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE VISION
AND THE POLICIES THROUGH THIS
PLAN CAN ONLY BE ACHIEVED WITH
NEW INVESTMENTS IN ARE YOU SEE --
BUDGET SO WE'RE EXCITED THAT THE
GOVERNOR OUT OF THE GATE IS
FOCUSED ON THE INCREASE
INVESTMENTS EARLY EDUCATION WE
KNOW THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS RIGHT
THERE WILLING TO PARTNER WITH
HIM.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE KNOW
THAT YOU SEE MATTERS WE KNOW
IT'S A DIFFERENCE MAKER --
FOR FAMILIES WE KNOW IT'S A
DIFFERENCE MAKER FOR PEOPLE
TRYING TO ENTER THE WORK FORCE
WE KNOW IT'S A DIFFERENCE MAKER.
IN TRYING TO ADJUST THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND ADDRESS
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY IN THE
WORKS AND SO WE HAVE BEFORE US
WE THINK IS A GOOD --
PLAN A ROADMAP TO GET US --
THAT WAY I KNOW WE HAVE A A
ROBUST HEARING TODAY SO --
WE'RE GONNA START A FEW MINUTES
BEFORE BEFORE A BIG GOT BEGIN WE
WANT TO ALLOW.
OUR CO CHAIRS AND OUR SPEAKER TO
LAUGH AND ALSO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO SAY A FEW INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS --
BECAUSE YOU'RE RUBIO.
THINK HE'S OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE SPEAKER --
AND TO MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE I THINK
THAT THE INVESTING IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS.
THE WHERE WE NEED TO BE --
AS OF HAPPENS BEFORE CHILDREN
ENTER KINDERGARTEN I TAUGHT
KINDERGARTEN FOR THREE YEARS SO
TRUST ME I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS --
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
FOR ALL OF THE KIDS TO BE
PREPARED SO THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL AND NOT
ONLY FOR THE CHILDREN BUT FOR
THE PARENTS AS WELL.
I APPRECIATE THE AMBITIOUS GOALS
OF ENSURING THAT ALL CHILDREN
BIRTH TO FIVE HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
AND A COMMITMENT TO STARTING
FIRST --
WITH THE CHILDREN WHO NEED IT
MOST.
BECAUSE THE FACE OF TOWN THE
CHALLENGING --
LIVES OF KIDS ARE BECAUSE OF
POVERTY AND I THINK THAT WITH A
GROUP GOOD EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FOUNDATION A GOOD
EDUCATION.
THOSE ARE THE TOOLS I HAVE TWO
LEFT FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY.
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT THE REPORT
RECOMMENDS THAT WE PRIORITY TO
PRIORITIZE --
INVESTMENTS --
MAINLY INFANTS AND TODDLERS --
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE TOO
MANY OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS AND THE
KEY HERE AND I THINK THROUGHOUT --
THE LAST TWO YEARS WE SPOKE
ABOUT GRAMS ARM [inaudible]
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE KIDS
ARE READY FOR SCHOOL AS WE
EXPAND OUR INVESTMENT IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE SHOULD
ENSURE THAT OUR MOST --
BOOK VULNERABLE CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS TO TRULY HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO SUPPORT THE BRAIN DEVELOPMENT --
WE KEEP HEARING STATISTICS ABOUT
HOW CRITICAL THOSE FIRST.
YEARS ARE AND I THINK THE
COMMISSION HAS DONE AN
OUTSTANDING JOB MAKING SURE THAT
WE ADDRESS THAT POPULATION I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR --
WE WERE VERY EXCITED WHEN HE
MENTIONED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND HIS --
AND HIS --
INAUGURATION SPEECH BUT ALSO THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS MET WITH HIM NOT
SO LONG AGO I THINK A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO AND THE FIRST THING
THAT WE ARE ASKED OF HIM WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT HE KEPT HIS
COMMITMENT. TO ARE THOSE
PROGRAMS THE FIRST PARTNER WAS
THERE AND SHE WAS SUPER EXCITED
ABOUT THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN DOING.
SO TRUST ME SHE WILL HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FOR HIS REMARKS
AND WE ASKED HIM FOR A
COMMITMENT RIGHT THEN AND THERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE DOES
SUPPORTED AND IT TRULY.
IT WASN'T TOO MUCH OF AN ASK HE
INDICATED THAT.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
I'D TO I AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
COMMISSION FOR THE GREAT WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE AND THANK YOU
TO MY FELLOW FELLOW COLLEAGUES.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
PUSHING AND I AM COMMITTED AS I
KNOW ON MY COLLEAGUES ARE TO
KEEP PUSHING FOR THE INVESTMENT
THAT WE NEED FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
I MOST ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
WHAT IS RUNNING.
I'M WE HAVE [inaudible]
CHEN ABOUT.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY ALL ABOUT.
WE HAVE.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS GOING TO BE FOR THE
CHILDREN --
IT'S IT'S BEEN A TASK THAT WAS
UNDERTAKEN I I THINK THE SPEAKER
FOR HIS VISION FOR SOMETHING
THIS IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THIS IS THIS IS BEEN PART
OF HIS LIFE.
BUT THE FACTTHAT HE HAS NOW PUT
TOGETHER THIS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION TO ALLOW.
THE COMMUNITY THE PARENTS AND
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO GET
TOGETHER AND THEN THE AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID FOR TWO
YEARS TO SPEND THE TIME TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS PARTICULAR REPORT.
AND I'D LIKE TO FACT THERE'S A
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
DURING THIS TIME THEY HAVE HEARD
FROM THE FAMILIES FROM THE
PARENTS FROM CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS EDUCATORS AND R. K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
AND SO MANY OTHERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THE REPORT.
IS THE PRODUCT OF CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE DURING THIS TIME.
ALL FOCUSED ON ONE GOAL HOW DO
WE BEST PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY AND
ACCESSIBLE CHILD HEARD EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
THE NEXT PART THOUGH IS YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE REPORT AND
THAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR YOUR COMMENTARIES TO
HELP ENSURE.
THAT THE REPORT IS COMPLETE IT
ISN'T JUST ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
PUT TOGETHER WHAT THE
COMMISSIONERS OF PUT TOGETHER IT
IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THE REPORT.
AND BECAUSE YOU BEEN INVOLVED
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS BECOME THAT MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT.
I WANT.
TO TELL YOU HOW PERSONALLY I
EXCITED I AM TO SEE THE ROLL OUT
OF THIS THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE POLICY --
WHICH WILL DIRECTLY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE WELL BEING OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AS CHAIR OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION POLICY THAT PROMOTES
EQUITY AND ACCESS WILL BE ONE OF
THE TOP PRIORITIES OF MY
COMMITTEE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SPRING FORWARD
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE GUIDELINES THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING.
THANK YOU MISS CULTURE --
IT JUST WANTED IS JUST SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL THE COMMISSION
MEMBERS FOR WITH THE COMPILING
JUST VERY COMPREHENSIVE REPORT.
I THINK IT HIGHLIGHTS ALL THE
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT WE
EXPERIENCE EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THEY REALLY HIGHLIGHTS MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES --
THE CHALLENGES WE KNOW ON
AUGMENT OUR BUDGET THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS TO REALLY SUPPORT
MANY OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
EFFORTS HOWEVER --
YOU SEE THE REPORT TALK ABOUT
THE LACK OF CLASSROOM SPACE A
LACK OF INTEGRATION --
INTIMATE CHALLENGES YOU HAVE
BECAUSE AT TIMES --
FAMILIES ISOLATED OR THE CENTERS
ARE ISOLATED.
SO AGAIN --
THIS THIS REPORTERS ARE A GREAT
JOB OF LAYING THE GROUNDWORK FOR
OUR AGENDA IN RELIEF FOR OUR
DIALOGUE I THINK.
THE CHALLENGE WILL BE FOR ALL OF
US TO BE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER.
IN PUSH FORWARD IN A COHESIVE
COORDINATED FASHION SO WE CAN
REALLY --
MAKE MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE WE KNOW
THAT IF WE CAN INVEST EARLY IN
CHILDREN.
IT PAYS OFF IN HUGE RETURNS DOWN
THE ROAD AND SO I THINK WE ARE
UP FOR THAT INVESTMENT I THINK
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
IN REALLY MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE THE MOST
STRATEGIC THINGS WE CAN BE DOING --
WITH OUR RESOURCES AND WITH. TO
CLOSE IT OUT --
THE INSPIRATION BEHIND THIS
ENTITY AND SOMEBODY CAME FROM
EASY FIELD OF COURSE SPEAKER
RENDON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS I'VE --
SURFACE SERVED IN THIS.
IN THIS --
BUILDING NOW FOR SIX YEARS AND
I'VE HAD SOME.
DAYS WHEN I WAS REALLY HAPPY --
SOME DAYS WHEN I WAS REALLY
UNHAPPY --
TODAY IS PROBABLY THE FIRST THEY
I'VE EVER BEEN.
GETTY.
THIS IS A REALLY REALLY COOL DAY --
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU --
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE HERE TODAY
ALL OF YOU WHO WERE HERE IN --
IN THE PAST --
THOSE OF YOU WHO WERE IN FRESNO
IN LONG BEACH IN COACHELLA AS WE
WENT UP AND DOWN THE STATE I
WANT TO THANK OUR FELLOW
COMMISSIONER FOR ALL OF THEIR
HARD WORK.
MR MCCARTY MIST --
WORLD CUP SEMI FINAL GAME
BETWEEN ENGLAND IN CROATIA.
JUST THE TO ADD A TERRIFIC COP --
I KNOW THERE WERE A LOT OF
SACRIFICES MADE IN THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INPUT AND
WE HAVE A A WONDERFUL DRAFT --
PROPOSAL HERE.
AND THIS PROCESS IN THIS DRAFT
PROPOSAL WAS ALL ABOUT IT'S ALL
ABOUT RESULTS IT'S ALL ABOUT
GETTING RESULTS.
ALL EIGHT HEARINGS OF THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION --
HAVE BEEN GREAT.
BUT I'M PARTICULARLY EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT COMES AFTER THAT WHAT
COMES AFTER THIS POINT WHICH IS
ABOUT AGAIN GEARED TOWARDS
GETTING RESULTS.
TODAY WE HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS
COMMISSION.
JUST AS EXCITING WILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM YOU THE
PUBLIC ABOUT OUR CONCLUSIONS.
THE ROUTE THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION HEARD FROM A NUMBER
OF EXPERTS WE KNOW THAT PARENTS
OF PROVIDERS HAVE EXPERTISE AS
IMPORTANT AS ANY ACADEMIC OR
GOVERNMENT ADMINISTRATOR HAS.
SO WE MADE SURE THAT YOU WERE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS.
THE TOPIC OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS RARELY FAR FROM MY
MIND FOR TWO REASONS AS HAS BEEN
STATED.
PREVIOUSLY THAT'S WHY I RAN FOR
OFFICE IT IT'S A FIELD IN WHICH
I SPENT.
THE FIRST TWENTY YEARS OF MY
CAREER.
IT UNDERPINS --
IT ALSO DEPENDS SO MUCH OF WISH
AS A SOCIETY I'M GLAD THAT WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO RECOGNIZES
THAT.
I SPOKE TO A GROUP OF YOUNG
POLITICAL SCIENCE STUDENTS LAST
WEEK I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST
WEDNESDAY.
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS WHOSE SOLE
GOAL WAS TO SHAPE THE FUTURE.
I SHARED WITH THEM THAT MY
CONVICTION THAT IT'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION THAT TURNS
AROUND COMMUNITIES.
IT'S EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
THAT BREAKS THE CYCLE OF POVERTY
IN FAMILIES IT'S EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THAT I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAM.
AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT WE
CAN OFFER.
IT'S HOW YOU GIVES CHILDREN A
STRONG FOUNDATION FOR EDUCATION
AND IT'S HOW YOU LOOKED UP
FAMILIES.
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION TO
LOOK AT IT THROUGH THIS LANDS
AND CONSIDERED HOW ECP SHOULD
ALLOW INCOME EARNERS TO STAY ON
THE JOB.
WHETHER THEY WORK DAYS WEEKENDS
ARE NICE.
AND THAT WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO ENSURE
EQUITY OF SERVICES.
B. R. SEE TOOK US AWAY FROM THE
CONSTANT BUDGET BATTLES INSTEAD
FOCUSED ON FIGHTING FOR FOR FIND
FIGHTING FOR CONSTANT DOLLARS.
BLUE RIBBON INSTEAD OF DOING SO
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION BEGIN
BY ASKING WHAT DO WE NEED HOW
SHOULD WE WRITE YOU SEE PROGRAMS.
THAT AND AGAIN THAT TOOK US AWAY
FROM THE CONSTANT BATTLE FOR
DOLLARS AND INSTEAD FOCUSES ON
FAMILIES AND FOCUSES ON CHILDREN.
AND AND THAT'S WHY I'M GETTY
TODAY.
WE CAN I GET STARTED TOO SOON ON
THE IDEAS WE HAVE PRODUCED SONG
TO GET OUT OF THE WAY SO WE CAN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT THANK YOU BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR PANEL I I DID WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS --
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE HERE
TODAY WE HAD COMMISSIONER
ALMANAC AHMADI MELON.
KHôNG THE NATION IS --
YALA AND ACROSS SKI I ALSO WHEN
TWO COMMISSIONERS ARE HERE TODAY
BUT THERE AND WASHING DC.
LOBBYING FOR EARLY EDUCATION
THAT'S COMMISSIONERS ON YOUR
COMPASS RIVERA AND COMMISSIONER
NEED A BOOTH THEME.
I THINK THEY'RE THE GOOD LUCK
CHARM BECAUSE THIS MORNING ON
THE WAY AND I HEARD ON NPR THAT
THE THE PRESIDENT.
THE MUCH MALIGNED FOR SOME OF US
POLICIES FOR CALIFORNIA.
PROPOSING TO INVEST AND NOT IN
ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CHILD CARE BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM ACROSS THE NATION.
SO THAT WOULD MEAN ROUGHLY --
CALIFORNIA'S ROUGHLY 10%
POPULATION SO YOU KNOW BACK OF
THE ENVELOPE AT LEAST A HUNDRED
MILLION MORE FOR CALIFORNIA. TO
RELATE TO IMPLEMENT THE PLAN WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY TO REALIZE
WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE THIS IS A
COMBINATION OF FEDERAL.
STATE AND LOCAL RESOURCES AS
WELL AS COURSE --
PARENTS AND BUSINESSES STEP UP
AND FILL THE PHILLY FILL THE
VOIDS AS WELL SO --
THAT'S SOME GOOD NEWS TO START
THIS MORNING SO WE'RE AS ACT AND
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM.
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES TODAY
AND SO WITH THAT WE WANT TO
INVITE AT OUR PARENT FOCUS GROUP.
TO PROVIDE A PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BE.
MORNING EVERYONE.
LARA PRIOR AND SENIOR SAYS IT IS
A POLICY RESEARCH.
IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY HELLO WHAT'S
LIKELY TO HAVE YOU ADD TO THE
MIKE PRESSED A LITTLE BUTTON
THE OTHER ONE BY YOUR RIGHT HAND
[inaudible]
HANNAH [inaudible]
SELECT COMMITTEE.
TESTING.
THERE WE GO.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
LAURA PRIOR AND I'M A SENIOR
ASSOCIATE AT SOCIAL POLICY
RESEARCH ASSOCIATES A RESEARCH
AND EVALUATION FIRM BASED OUT OF
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
PARTNERING WITH PARENTS VOICES
ON THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
TOGETHER PARENTS PERSPECTIVES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO INFORM
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
SUPPORT. FOR IMPROVING EARLY
LEARNING IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROJECT CULMINATED IN A
FINAL REPORT TITLED WAITING TO
BE SEEN DEMANDING TO BE HEARD.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WHICH IS NOW PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
BEFORE GIVING A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF OUR PROJECT I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NECESSITY OF
CENTERING THE PERSPECTIVES OF
THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY CHILD
CARE POLICIES AND SINCERELY BANK
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION FOR
SUPPORTING THIS INVALUABLE
EFFORT.
SOCIAL POLICY RESEARCH
ASSOCIATES AND PARENT VOICES SEE
PARENTS AS THE EXPERTS WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILD CARE REFORM.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS WORK WE
COMMITTED TO CONDUCTING FOR
PARENT FOCUS GROUPS AS A WAY TO
LIFT UP AND SHOWCASE PARENTS
WITH THEM.
AS A MEMBER OF THE RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
UNIQUE APPROACH.
WHILE MANY RESEARCH PROJECTS MAY
STRIVE TO INCORPORATE MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT
COMMUNITY VOICE IS MEANING
POLICE ENTERED AND POLICY
RESEARCH.
THERE FOR THIS PROJECT PROVIDED
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN
TO PARENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE AIM TO INCLUDE AS MANY
PERRANCE AS POSSIBLE BY MAKING
THESE FOCUS GROUPS ACCESSIBLE
AND CHILD FRIENDLY.
THIS SPENT CONDUCTING THESE
FOCUS GROUPS IN THE EVENINGS ON
THE WEEKENDS PROVIDING FREE
CHILDCARE SPANISH TRANSLATION
FOOD IN THE STATE AND FOR
PARENTS TIME.
IN TOTAL WE CONDUCTED FOR FOCUS
GROUPS SPEAKING WITH THIRTY
THREE PARENTS IN INGLEWOOD LOS
ANGELES THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
FRESNO IN THE BAY AREA.
REPRESENTING URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL AREAS.
THE FRESNO FOCUS GROUP WAS
CONDUCTED ENTIRELY IN SPANISH.
PARENTS ARE PREDOMINATELY LOW
INCOME MOTHERS FROM IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE ALSO HAD TWO FATHERS A TENDER
FOCUS GROUPS IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY.
THESE PARENT EXPERIENCES
REPRESENTED EVERY CHILD CARE
SETTING INCLUDING CENTER BASED
CARE FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES
STATE PRESCHOOL HEAD START IN
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE.
ORIGINALLY WE INTENDED TO HOST A
FOCUS GROUP IN CHICO HOWEVER THE
CAMPFIRE PREVENTED US IN
CARRYING OUT THESE PLANS.
IF WE ARE TO PRINT IF WE WERE TO
CONDUCT A FOLLOW UP PROJECT WE
STRIVE TO INCLUDE THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE AS WELL
AS THE TRIBAL NATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE STRUCTURED EACH FOCUS GROUPS
THAT IT WOULD BE A CONVERSATION
AMONG PARENTS GUIDED BY A FEW
OVER ARCHING QUESTIONS WE BEGAN
THE FOCUS GROUP BY ASKING
PARENTS TO DISCUSS THEIR IDEAL
WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO FINDING
AND KEEPING QUALITY CHILD CARE.
IT'S DESCRIBED.
A WORLD IN WHICH WAITING LIST
DID NOT EXIST WARM HAND OFF FOR
PROVIDED THAT PRENATAL
APPOINTMENTS MULTIPLE QUALITY
CHILDCARE OPTIONS WERE OFFERED
AT FLEXIBLE HOURS.
IN PARIS RETREAT WITH CARE AND
RESPECT GETTING THE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM.
AFTER DESCRIBING THEIR IDEAL
WORLD PARENTS THEN DISCUSS THE
ON THE GROUND CHILD CARE
REALITIES WHICH ARE FAR FROM
IDEAL.
PARENTS TOLD STORIES OF FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS DUE TO LOSING
ELIGIBILITY WITHOUT BEING
NOTIFIED IN STAYING ON WAITING
LISTS FOR OVER SEVEN YEARS.
YOU CAN READ THE DETAILS OF THE
STORIES IN OUR REPORT.
MY PARENTS NEVER ENDED THE
CONVERSATION THERE.
THE FOCUS GROUPS ALWAYS ENDED
WITH PARENTS SHARING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
THE PURPOSE WAS NOT JUST TO
COLLECT RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
SAKE OF DOCUMENTATION.
BUT TO BRING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CAPITAL
TO BE TURNED IN THE POLICIES
THAT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
ALL NOW PASS IT OFF TO MONEY VIA
LUNA ONE OF THE PARENTS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE BAY AREA OF
FOCUS GROUP WILL PRESENT ASET
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
EXPLAIN HOW SOME OF THEM HAVE
ALREADY BEEN TURNED.
INTO CAMPAIGN FOR THIS
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE FULL SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS CAN BE FOUND
IN OUR REPORT WHICH IS AVAILABLE
AT THE TABLE BEHIND ME.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAHDI A PART OF
THE PAIR PLACES THEIR JUST GO
CHAPTER.
A SOLO PARENTS OF A THREE YEAR
OLD.
WAS ALSO NOT FEELING WELL AND
WHEN YOUR KID IS SICK.
THEY DON'T GO TO CHILD CARE.
SO I PARTICIPATING THE BLUE
RIBBON PAIR FOCUS GROUP AND IT
WAS THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
BEEN A FOCUS GROUP OF PARENTS.
WITH THE SAME ECONOMIC STRUGGLES.
AROUND TALK HERE THAT I HAVE.
IT FELT LIKE A SUPPORT GROUP BUT
WE WERE HEARD AND OUR EXPERIENCE
AS PARENTS.
AND AS EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF
CHILD CARE WERE VALIDATED TO
NOTE TAKING RECORDINGOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND TO THE
PUBLISHING.
OF THIS REPORT THE YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
PLEASE CONSIDER THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS IF YOU HAD A
THINK TANK OR UNIVERSITY.
PROFESSOR IN FRONT OF YOU
BECAUSE THIS IS FIRST HAND
SCHOLARSHIP.
IT'S A CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
SO WE HEARD A LOT FROM FAMILIES
IN THE COW WORK PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE WEIRD A LOT FOR FAMILY THE
COWARDS PROGRAM WE LEARNED THAT.
THEY WERE TOLD ABOUT CHILD CARE
BENEFITS WITH CAL WORKS --
THAT THE PROCESS WAS HARD TO
NAVIGATE THAT IT TOOK A LONG
TIME TO GET APPROVED SOME TALK
ABOUT HAVING CHILDCARE BUT THEN
THEY LOST IT BECAUSE SOMEBODY
LOST THEIR PAPERWORK.
OR BECAUSE THEY WERE TRANSITION
TO STAGE TO CHILD CARE PROPERLY.
FOR ME I WAS WORKING MY DREAM
JOB.
WAS STABLE AND READY. TO HAVE A
CHILD.
LITTLE DID I KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE
IT WAS DARK.
LITTLE EXPENSE.
LITTLE DID HE KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE
AND HARD. TO FIND QUALITY
CHILDCARE.
I COULDN'T AFFORD IT I HAD TO GO
CAL CARE.
MY CHILD CARE WAS APPROVED UNTIL
TWO MONTHS AFTER I READ IS
APPROVED FOR CASH AID.
AND BY THAT TIME MY JOB HAD
THREE PLEASE.
NOT HAVING TO ARGUMENT THE DEATH
OF MY CAREER.
SO WE WILL BE THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL'S SB THREE TWO ONE
STRONG SERVER TOWERS FAMILIES
WELL SURE THAT NO FAMILY HAS
EXPERIENCE LIKE I DID.
THIS BILL WOULD APPROVE TALKER
AS SOON AS YOU GET CASH IN.
AND THEN YOU CAN HAVE IT FOR
TWELVE MONTHS JUST LIKE THE REST
OF THE TOP HIS SYSTEM.
WE ALTERED FOR MANY PARENTS THAT
CAN IF I LICENSE STOCK YOU'RE
NEAR THEM.
SO.
THERE PROVIDE THE PROVIDERS ARE
PAID SO LITTLE THEY CAN AFFORD
TO TAKE THE FAMILY TO SUBSIDIES.
AND AND SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO AT
THE FAMILY OR FRIEND TO GET PAID
AROUND THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
REALIZING THE EXACT PART TIME
CARE.
AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MONN WILL
HELP FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THE LICENSES THAT PROVIDERS GET
A SEAT AT THE TABLE TO FIGHT FOR
BETTER WAGES THAT THEY DESERVE.
AND HELPED US AS PARENTS ACT
ACCESS WATCH OUT YOUR OPTIONS.
REGARD TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE
HEARD ONE MOTHER.
WHO PRAYED THAT THEY WOULD GIVE
BIRTH ON A FRIDAY?
SO THEY CAN GO BACK TO WORK ON
MONDAY.
MANY PARENTS DIDN'T TAKE PARENTS
LEAVE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO NOT EARN THEIR FULL SALARY.
WE KNOW THE BILL THAT WILL
EXPAND PAID FAMILY LEAVE INCLUDE
INCREASING THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
21100%. FOR LOW INCOME WORKERS
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY USE THIS
PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HEARD A LOT FROM PARENTS
WERE BEING TREATED POORLY BY
CASE WORKERS ACROSS ALL SYSTEMS.
IMAGINE WALKING INTO THE
CALVERTS OFFICE THE FIRST PHASE
THE UC.
IS NOT A CASE MANAGER IT'S A
SECURITY GUARD.
THE GUARD WHO DOESN'T HAVE ANY.
USE OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE.
I MYSELF BY THE SECURITY GUARD
TOWERS OFFICE BEEN TOLD I NEED
TO GET A JOB --
I DON'T LIKE WORKING WITH PEOPLE
LIKE YOU --
AND SO THESE ARE THE EXPERIENCES
THAT WERE HAVING SO MANY OF US
SUFFER FOR TOM OPPRESSION
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HEARTS OF
JUST BEING POVERTY.
SO THOSE ARE JUST GOING THROUGH
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS
ALREADY RE TRAUMATIZING.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO AGENCIES
SEEKING HELP.
OUR MOM IT DESCRIBES RATE OF
TAKE PIPER CAL WORKS WITH
VISIBLE BRUISES ONE TIRED AND
SHE WAS DECLARED TO BE THE
METHOD VIOLENCE VICTIM.
SHE WAITED THE ENTIRE DAY TO BE
HELD TO ONLY TO BE TREATED
RUDELY.
AT ISSUE WAS A CRIMINAL. TO
ADDRESS THIS WE RECOMMEND THAT
CASE WORKERS WORK WITH FAMILIES
AND TALKING PROVIDERS ARE
TRAINED IN OF TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE AND RECOGNIZING A PLEASANT
PRICE BIAS.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT WE START
NOT ONLY HIRING MORE BILINGUAL
STAFF.
BUT ALSO STAFF WHO CAN ACT
ACTIVE CULTURAL NAVIGATORS. ONE
PAIR DESCRIBED HOW THEY WANT TO
APPLY FOR SERVICES AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY PROVIDED SOME WAS
BOOKED THEIR LANGUAGE.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO TRANSLATE
THE CON.
OF WHAT NEEDED TO BE EXPLAINED.
SO IF THEY HAD A CASE WORKER
[inaudible]
WHO WAS?
WHO WAS FROM THE SAME COUNTRY
THAT THEY WERE IN UNDERSTOOD THE
DIFFERENCES?
OF BOTH CULTURES IT WOULD HAVE
HELPED THEM ACCESS THEIR
SERVICES IN A MORE MEANINGFUL
LIFE SO NOT JUST INTERPRETATION
BUT ALSO CULTURAL NAVIGATION AS
WELL --
MYSELF I KNOW THAT WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO TALK TO ANYONE WITH
TRAVEL CHILD CARE IN THIS
PROCESS.
KNOW THAT YOU SPOKE WITH BUT I
MYSELF.
I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH TRIBES IN
THAT WOULD --
SORRY.
SO ALSO AND BEING PART NATIVE
AMERICAN WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE NEED FOR CULTURAL NAVIGATORS.
WHO COME FROM THE ACTUAL TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES FOR THEM TO
BASICALLY APPROACH TRAVEL CHILD
CARE AND THE WAY THAT WORKS
SPECIFICALLY TO THEIR
SOVEREIGNTY AND THEIR TRIBAL
NATIONS?
SO NOT ONLY SUPPORTING JUST NEED
AMERICA RATES BUT ALL PARENTS
FOR DIFFERENT CULTURES WITH
CULTURE APPROPRIATE WAYS.
THE LAST NAVIGATION --
LAST WHAT'S UP LIFT IS REGARDING
AROUND QUEER FAMILIES ARE
FAMILIES DON'T THAT DON'T FIT
INTO THE MOTHER FATHER TO PEER
FAMILY BOX.
ON THIS IS SOMETHING WE DON'T
HEAR MUCH ABOUT BUT I MYSELF
HAVE FILLED OUT FORMS AROUND
CHILDCARE SEEN THE WORDS MOTHER
FATHER.
SO FOR PARENTS WHO ARE NON
BINARY WE'RE TRANCE MIGHT BE A
GRANDMA WHO MIGHT BE A FOSTER
PARENT.
THESE FORMS IN THESE WORDS APPLY
TO US.
SO.
I KNOW THAT --
THERE WAS THE L. G. B. T. JUST
CUTE DISPARITIES ACT THAT
HAPPENED WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOT ONLY STATE AGENCIES
UPDATE THERE FOR TO BE MORE
GENDER NEUTRAL.
BUT TO ALSO INCLUDE THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION CHANGES --
SO THAT COULD BE A FORCE RIGHT
NOW THAT'S NOT INCLUDED --
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
REST OF ALL THE STATE AGENCIES
CATCH UP SO WE CAN SEE THE ALL
TYPES OF PARENTS IN ALL TYPES OF
CHILDREN.
AND GENDERS OF REPRESENTED AND
ALSO DIFFERENT AT THE FAMILIES
RIGHT IT'S TWENTY NINETEEN AND
I'VE SEEN LOTS OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF FAMILIES.
REPRESENTED.
SO -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING WITH
MY CHILD [inaudible]
HERE'S YOUR GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS CARLENE US
VIA I LIVE IN HANFORD AND
HANFORD CALIFORNIA HERE I HAVE A
THREE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND A
FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
SO THESE SERVICES HAVE ACTUALLY
HELPED ME IT'S ABOUT TO BE
ALMOST TWO YEARS.
SO I'M GONNA --
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT OF OF WHAT I
HAD PREPARED FOR YOU GUYS IN
THIS WALL SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF
MY STORY.
SO I COME HERE TODAY ASKING YOU
TO PLEASE SUPPORT AB ONE NINETY
FOUR I AM ONE OF MANY OF
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH CHILD CARE TO
CONTINUE EMPLOYMENT.
OF OUR DREAM CARE SYSTEM WOULD
BE FOR THERE TO BE NO WAITING
LIST BECAUSE NO PARENT HAS THE
LUXURY OF WAITING TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
SOMETIMES THERE ARE SOME
CHILDREN WHO WOULD GET AXES BUT
OTHERS IN THE HOUSEHOLD WHAT IT
SO THIS WOULD BE IN MY
EXPERIENCE --
BECAUSE OF MY MY DAUGHTER MY SON
HAVE A TWO YEAR AGE DIFFERENCE
SO DEPENDING ON THE AGES THEY
HAVE.
MORE --
AVAILABILITY SO MY SON WAS ABLE
TO GET AFTER --
A FIVE MONTH WAITING WHEN I
MOVED HE WAS ABLE TO GET CHILD
CARE BUT MY DAUGHTER WHAT IT SO
THEN -- THAT
JUST ADDS STRUGGLE ON TOP OF NOT
BEING ABLE. TO TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR CHILDREN ARE GETTING
EDUCATION THAT THEY'RE SAFE FOR
YOUR OWN WORK --
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO
PROVIDE FOR THEM WE NEED TO WORK
FOR THEM NEED TO FEED THEM.
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS I
WAS DONE BECAUSE ONE GETS IT
THAT'S A GREAT THING YOU KNOW
BUT IT'S STILL PUTS THAT
PRESSURE ON YOU --
THAT FINANCIAL PRESSURE.
SO I KNOW THAT THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE HOW IT IS OF BEING ON
EXPERIENCE OF A WAITING LIST AND
I KNOW THE STRUGGLE IN THE
FINANCIAL STRUGGLE.
IT WAS EITHER PAY RENT OR PAY
CHILD CARE I KNOW MANY PARENTS
WHO CANNOT EVEN AFFORD TO WORK.
FOR MONTHS I HAD TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET AND AFTER MY RIGHT IT WAS
NEARLY --
THE REST OF MY PAYCHECK SO I
REALLY WHAT I HAVE TO DO IS AS
WE KNOW YOU HAVE TO WORK TO GET
TO WHERE YOU CAN'T JUST.
DO SO ONLY EDUCATION AND THEN
EXPECT TO HAVE YOUR DREAM JOB
YOU HAVE TO WORK YOUR WAY UP
ALONG WITH SCHOOL.
SO IN ORDER FOR ME TO EVEN SAY
OKAY I HAVE A SHOT OF DOING WHAT
I WANT TO DO AND PROVIDE FOR MY
FAMILY HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IN THE MEANWHILE I HAVE TO BE
WORKING SO FOR ME TO GET THERE I
HAVE TO PAY BASICALLY.
PACE SO THAT I COULD CONTINUE TO
WORK SO I COULD GET SOMEWHERE
AND HAVE MY MY LITTLE ONES BEING
TAKEN CARE.
I LIVED IN AN AREA WHERE THERE
WERE ONLY TWO LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS SO THOSE
WERE ONLY OPTIONS AND THAT'S IF
THE WARRANT FOR SO YOU'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW SURE THAT YOU HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL THEY'RE DONE AND THEN
SEE IF YOU GET A SHOT TO GET IN
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW THERE'S LONG
WAITING LISTS AND I'M.
QUITE A BIT OF AN ADVOCATE FOR
MYSELF SO I WAS ALWAYS CALLING
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE YOU KNOW
HE HOW WHAT THIS YEAR'S HAVE
THIS READY CAN I GO AND AND
EVERYBODY WAS ALWAYS HELPFUL AND
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT THAT THEY
HELP BUT IT'S JUST.
RESOURCES THAT WAS A I KNOW THAT
THEY WANTED TO HELP BUT THERE
WAS NOBODY ELSE THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE THAT THEY COULD DO.
SO -- AT ONE
POINT IT TOOK LIKE FIVE MONTHS
OF YOUR ME TO START MY
EMPLOYMENT --
ARE I MEAN TO GET THE CHILD CARE
SO WITHIN THAT TIME ALL OF MY
INCOME BASICALLY WENT TO THE
CHILD CARE I COULDN'T PAY FOR
RENT THAT WAS OUT OF THE PICTURE
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF THAT I PAY
FOR RENT IS THE AMOUNT THAT I
WOULD PAY FOR CHILDCARE.
SERVICE EITHER OR SO THEN ONCE I
WAS FINALLY ABLE TO GET ON THE
PROGRAM I WAS FINALLY ABLE TO
MOVE OUT AND YOU KNOW BE AN
ADULT BECAUSE I ACTUALLY HAD
MONEY LEFT OVER AFTER TWO LITTLE
ONES -- SO
AFTER THAT I HAD TO DRIVE AN
HOUR TO GET TO FOR MY COMMUTE TO
GO TO WORK.
SO I DECIDED TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE CLOSER TO MY WORK SO THAT
MEANT ANOTHER WAITING LISTS FOR
THE DIFFERENT CHILD CARE --
PLACE AND THAT WAS WHERE I HAD
THE DIFFICULTY WITH MY SON AND
MY DAUGHTER NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
SEEN IN THE SAME PLACE.
SO IN A DREAMER MORE REALITY.
WOULD BE TO HAVE MORE
UNINTERRUPTED CARE AS SOON AS WE
HAVE TO RETURN TO WORK AND THE
WHOLE FAMILY CAN BE SERVE NOT
JUST ONE CHILD AND THAT'S VERY
STRESSFUL AND VERY COSTLY.
I KNOW SO MANY FAMILIES WHO JUST
NEED HELP PAYING FOR CHILDCARE
AND THEY END UP HAVING TO QUIT.
SO IN IN REFERENCE A LITTLE AN
ELIGIBILITY WORKER SO IT IS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT
OF FAMILIES WHO COME TO MEAND
SAY.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
BUT I DO KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE I'M
THERE YOU KNOW I'M THERE AND AND
IT'S A STRUGGLE BECAUSE BECAUSE
YOU MAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
MEANS YOU DON'T.
YOU MAKE TOO MUCH TO GET
ASSISTANCE WHEN IT'S STILL
YOU'RE STILL IN THAT MIDDLE PART.
SO I'M NOT I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO STOP AND
THIS IS EVERY DAY IN MY
EMPLOYMENT I SEE FAMILIES THAT
HAVE TO STOP BECAUSE THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY. FOR THEM TO GET THE
ASSISTANCE INSTEAD OF THEY HAVE
TO MANDATORY GO THROUGH CAL
WORKS THAT'S THEIR ONLY WAY OUT.
AND QUITTING WORK TO GET CHILD
CARE MAKES NO SENSE.
AND SPEAKING OF THE PARENTS AND
WORKING --
MY GREAT COMMUNITIES OUT OF THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE TO WORK --
AND HAVE TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN
OFTEN TO PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THEY'RE AT THE HOURS I MEAN A
LOT OF THE LABOR HOURS IN
AGRICULTURE EARLY MORNING
SOMETIME WEEKENDS.
AND THEY'RE NOT EVEN THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO DO ALL OF THAT BECAUSE
THE HOURS ARE VERY RESTRICTED --
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S I
MEAN.
THE PARENTS CAN'T EVEN FOCUS
JUST ON WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE
LIKE OKAY HOW WHO'S GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF MY CHILDREN
TOMORROW ARE THEY GOING TO BE
SAFE IS IT GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT IS GOING.
TO BENEFIT THEM IN THE LONG RUN
ARE THEY GOING TO BE EDUCATED --
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF MY
STORY THE CAN I PLEASE ASK YOU
GUYS TO SUPPORT AB ONE NINETY
FOUR FOR ALL OF OUR FAMILIES AND
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN'S FUTURES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WE HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE FOR THE PANEL.
YES MISTER MCMILLAN.
FROM FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR FOR SHOWING UP AND
MAHDI.
YOU WERE RIGHT ON THE MONEY
ABOUT THE THE NON BINARY
FAMILIES WE HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FAMILIES --
PRESENT DAY AND SO I KNOW WITH
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE ARE
ADDRESSING THAT AND WE'VE HAD
BRIEF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
HERE SO WHAT YOU JUST SHARED IT
DOESN'T FALL ON DEAF EARS.
WE HEAR YOU --
AND THE OTHER NO LESS.
AND I ALSO.
FEEL YOUR PAIN TO BECAUSE I'M A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER.
AND I ALSO FEEL YOUR PAIN
BECAUSE I ALSO KNOW THAT THERE
IS THERE IS A PROBLEM.
WHEN A MOTHER HAS ONE CHILD IN
CHILDCARE SHE GETS PREGNANT AND
HAS ANOTHER CHILD AND THAT'S HOW
KICK IT IN?
AND SO THAT THAT POSES TO BE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND SO THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THAT AND MAKE AND I
THINK WE ALL.
HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY SO I
ALSO WANT TO SAY HEY TO ALL OF
MY ORGANIZES SISTERS OUT THERE
AND THERE IS A GROUP ON FACEBOOK
YOU GUYS.
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD CARE
NETWORK AND THEY ARE WEARING
THESE WHITE SCARS AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT WITH THOSE FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS I'M PUTTING MY
WIFE'S CAR PHONE NOW.
IN SOLIDARITY WITH THEM SO THANK
YOU GUYS FOR SURE WHAT YOU
SHOULD WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE
SHARED WITH US TODAY.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER MCCLOSKEY.
SO I AM A UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR
AND I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU
MORE YOU GUYS ARE THE ONES WHO
HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN THE ONES
WHO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES EVERY
DAY.
THE REPORT IS FABULOUS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING AND
CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE SCENE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE NEXT --
SEGMENT OF TODAY'S.
HEARING AND AS A SPEAKER SAID
THIS IS THE REALLY EXCITING PART
BECAUSE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
WRITING PATCHWORK.
EVERY YEAR IN THE BUDGET IN
PIECE BY PIECE TODAY WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE AND WHERE
WE OUGHT TO BE AS FAR AS MAKING
SURE THAT WE INVEST IN.
IN THE WHOLE CHILD ESPECIALLY
WITH KIDS IN THE AGES OF ZERO
THREE FIVE SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
COMMISSIONER DEBT KHôNG TO GIVE
US -- A
PRESENTATION ON THE PRINCIPLE
BEFORE US AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME PRESENTATIONS ON
SECTIONS FROM COMMISSIONERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND THANKS TO PEOPLE LIKE THE
PARENTS AND RESEARCHER WHO JUST
SPOKE THE SPEAKER MEMBERS.
OTHER COMMUNITY COMMISSIONERS
THE STAFF AND ALL OF YOU.
THE COMMISSION'S INPUT PROCESS
HAS BEEN DEEP AN AUTHENTIC AND I
FEEL SO PRIVILEGED TO HAVE BEEN
A PART OF IT.
WE SPENT MANY HOURS LISTENING
AND WRESTLING WITH COMPLEX
ISSUES AND IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
FUN LEARNING WITH AND FROM ALL
OF YOU.
WE BEGIN WITH PRINCIPLES THAT WE
ADOPTED IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THEY HAVE BEEN USED
AS A STATEMENT OF OUR VISION AND
A GUIDE TO EVALUATE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'RE CALLING FOR SIGNIFICANT
REFORMS AROUND EQUITY AND TO
GENERATION POLICIES.
FROM THE START WE'VE EMPHASIZED
THE COMPREHENSIVE NATURE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ADDRESSING ALL OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT WE NEED FOR A ROBUST
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM.
THAT WORKS BETTER FOR OUR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND THOSE WHO
CARE FOR AND EDUCATE THEM.
THE COMMISSION'S WORK AS
INTENDED TO LAY OUT A LONG TERM
VISION FOR THE FUTURE AND TO
TRANSCEND YEAR TO YEAR SHORT
TERM DISCUSSIONS.
IN WHICH SOMEONE AND SOME LIVES.
WE KNOW WE WILL ONLY ACHIEVE
SYSTEMIC CHANGE IF WE INVEST
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND ACCESS
COMPENSATION.
AND THE SYSTEM ITSELF AND ENSURE
INCLUSIVE GOVERNANCE.
WITH THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WE REALLY DO
WANT TO MOVE ALL OF THESE PIECES
TOGETHER.
HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION THAT IS ACCESSIBLE AND
MEETS THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES.
AND EFFECTIVE AND PROFESSIONALLY
SUPPORTED WORK FORCE.
INTEGRATION WITH OTHER SYSTEMS
THAT SUPPORT CHILDREN FAMILY
SUCH AS EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION.
AND FINANCING THAT IS STABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE IN SUPPORT ALL OF
THESE THINGS AT A LEVEL THAT
GETS TO THE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
YOUNG KIDS NEED AND DESERVE.
AS SOON AS A FEW WORDS ABOUT HOW
WE GATHERED INFORMATION FOR
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS YOU HEARD OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE HELD HEARINGS ACROSS
THE STATE FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE BAY
AREA AND SACRAMENTO IN LOS
ANGELES.
WE TOURED A RANGE OF SETTINGS
THAT PROVIDE CARE AND EDUCATION
FOR KIDS FROM FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOMES TO NONPROFIT PROVIDERS TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
WE'VE.
COLLABORATED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND SURVEYED MORE THAN THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS.
COMMISSION MEMBERS ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN OTHER PLANNING
AND ANALYSIS EFFORTS AND WE
CAREFULLY REVIEW THEIR FINDINGS.
WE HAVE PRESENTED OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
OTHER KEY LEGISLATORS.
AND THE SPEAKER --
GIVEN THE REPORT.
AND WE HAVE DRAWN UPON CURRENT
AND PAST PROPOSALS MODELS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN OTHER
STATES.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND NINE KEY
TOPIC AREAS WHICH WILL BE
COVERED BY MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS WERE INFORMED BY
SUB COMMITTEES WHICH HAVE MADE
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
ALL AND BY RECOGNIZING WHAT I
KNOW WE ALL FEEL THAT THIS IS
SUCH AN EXCITING MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR LONGER THAN I HAVE BUT IN
THE TWELVE YEARS OR SO SINCE
I'VE BEEN AN ADVOCATE THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE MAJOR CHANGES.
WE SEE THIS AS AN IMPORTANT
REPORT AND WE ALSO WANT TO SEE
THE WORK CONTINUE BEYOND THIS
DOCUMENT.
SO YOU'LL SEE PROPOSALS FOR MORE
POWERFUL AND INCLUSIVE COUNCILS
THAT WILL LEAD TO STRONG VOICES
PUSHING FOR CHANGE INCLUDING
LEGISLATORS.
FAMILIES THE WORK FORCE AND MANY
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M SO EXCITED TO HEAR FROM ALL
OF YOU.
AND FIRST ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS TO PRESENT
RECOMMENDATIONS IN EACH OF THE
NINE AREAS.
A GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY --
I AM VERY PLACES THE STATE
ORGANIZER PREPARE VOICES OF BEEN
A COMMUNITY COMMISSIONER AND I'M
GOING TO DISCUSS --
SOME BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND OUR ACCESS --
RECOMMENDATIONS --
AS YOU SON WITNESSED --
AND WITH OUR REPORT --
WAS COMMITTED TO FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AT EVERY LEVEL
WEATHER WAS PUTTING MYSELF ON
THIS COMMISSION OR CREATING THE
PROCESS TO ENABLE FAMILIES TO BE.
THE EXPERTS AND REALLY BE SEEN
AS THE EXPERTS AND THIS
COMMISSION AND AND THE REPORT
REALLY REFLECTS THAT.
ENGAGEMENT IS TWO WAYS IT'S NOT
JUST FROM THE PRACTITIONER TO
THE FAMILY BUT IT'S ALSO.
FROM THE FAMILY BACK TO US --
I THINK WE REALLY REFLECTED THAT
WHEN YOU.
SEE PARENTS WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
PARENTS --
WHEN YOU HEAR WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING AND THEN TURN IT INTO
ACTION --
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BEST
RECIPE FOR REALLY IMPROVING OUR
SYSTEMS AND WHILE THIS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE PARENTS
ARE SORT OF AN ADDENDUM TO THE
REPORT.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE THAT THERE THEY
ARE ALL INTEGRATED THROUGHOUT
ALL OF THE THEMES IN THE REPORT
AND I THINK THIS COMMISSION CAN
REALLY -- BE
SEEN AS A MODEL FOR HOW TO DO
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT RIGHT I JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE IT FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART --
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IS
ALSO TO CREATE --
AND ESTABLISH A PARENT ADVISORY
COUNCIL --
NOT FOR LIP SERVICE --
NOT TO AND YOU KNOW OF LIKE REAL
TEETH AND MAKE SURE THAT ANY
PROPOSAL THAT'S GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
ARE VETTED FIRST THROUGH THOSE
FAMILIES SO THAT YOU ACTUALLY
CAN ADDRESS OBSTACLES AND
BARRIERS ON THE FRONT AND
INSTEAD OF ON THE BACK AND WHEN
IT'S AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE --
I THINK THAT WHAT MONEY
DESCRIBED --
IN HER RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE --
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT REALLY HAS.
TO START AT WILL REALLY LEAD TO
CULTURE SHIFTS IN HOW WE TREAT --
FAMILIES WHO ARE COMING TO
SUPPORT SHE DESCRIBED THE
SECURITY GUARDS --
WE HEARD FROM SO MANY FAMILIES
JUST THIS YOU KNOW --
ENVIRONMENT OF FRAUD DETECTION
AND AND CRIMINALIZATION AND WE
NEED TO REMOVE THAT SO THAT WE
CAN ALL WORK IN AS PARTNERS.
IN ACHIEVING THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE NEED --
IN REGARDS TO THE ACCESS
RECOMMENDATIONS --
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING IN THE
HAAS INSTITUTE FROM UC BERKELEY --
STEVEN --
MEN INDIAN CAME AND SPOKE TO THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION HEARING
AND INTRODUCED US TO A TOPIC
CALLED TARGETED UNIVERSALISM.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ACCESS
SOMETIMES UNIVERSAL ACCESS RIGHT --
AND THAT IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS
TO HAVE UNIVERSAL ACCESS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES --
BUT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT UNIVERSAL
ACCESS IS THAT THAT CAN OFTEN
MEAN THAT THOSE WHO HAVE THE
LEAST BARRIERS AND OBSTACLES ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
PROGRAMS FIRST.
AND SO --
WHAT WHAT HE TALKED TO US ABOUT
WAS TARGETED UNIVERSALISM AND
THAT'S HOW WE LAID OUT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND ACCESS SO
YOU'LL SEE THAT WHILE THE
UNIVERSAL GOAL --
WOULD BE THAT NO PARENT --
PAYS MORE THAN 7% OF THEIR
INCOME TOWARDS THE COST OF CARE --
IN BETWEEN WE HAVE SHORT TERM
MID TERM --
GOALS -- ONE
WOULD BE.
SERVING FAMILIES WHO MAKE UNDER
1100% OF THE SEPT SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY MEASURE WHICH DEFINITELY
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA --
THE NEXT GOAL WOULD BE TO SERVE
FAMILIES --
BELOW 70% OF THE STATE MEDIAN
INCOME --
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE AN IDEA
AROUND --
ESTABLISHING A ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM EMERGENCY
SERVICES FUND AND THIS IS A
RECOGNITION THAT.
ON OUR WAITING LIST AND ARE.
ARE COOKED AND WHICH IS NOT A
THANKS KRISTIN SCHUMACHER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER.
YOU KNOW SHE'S TOLD US THAT WE
HAD TWO MILLION ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN --
ON WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR CHILD
CARE SERVICES 86% OF THEM ARE
CHILDREN OF COLOR --
AND A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THEM
ARE WAITING FOR CHILDCARE BUT
OUR EXPERIENCE SEEN CRISIS RIGHT
NOW THESE ARE HOMELESS FAMILIES
THESE ARE --
FAMILIES IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM -- IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
FAMILIES TOWARD ARE DEALING WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND BY WAITING
FOR CHILD CARE WERE ONLY
EXACERBATING THAT TRAUMA.
AND SO BY PULLING OFF THOSE
FAMILIES AND HAVING AN EMERGENCY
FUND WE ALSO ARE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT EATING FAMILIES
IN CRISIS AGAINST THE WORKING
POOR FAMILIES WHO ARE ONE CRISIS
AWAY FROM FROM JOINING THEM SO
THAT WE CAN REALLY.
TRY TO SERVE BOTH FAMILIES.
SO AGAIN MORE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE FULL REPORT BUT WE JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
HIGHLIGHTS SO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
AND IT'S BEEN A A GREAT JOURNEY
BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET WE JUST
GETTING ON THE BUS.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR WORK FORCE --
IT'S LIKE THE PARENTS THAT WERE
HERE BEFORE WITHOUT THE CHILDREN.
WE WOULD HAVE NO JOBS AND
WITHOUT.
THE WORK FORCE WE CAN TALK ABOUT
A QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REALLY FOCUSED AND THE WORK THAT
WE LOOKED AT IN TERMS OF
STARTING WITH THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE REPORT.
OF TRANSFORMING THE WORK.
FOUR ZERO TWO EIGHT WE LOOKED AT
A LOT OF THE THE CENTER OF STUDY
FOR CHILDREN --
FOR CHILDCARE I TO BERKELEY WE
LOOKED AT REPORT FROM A ARE WE
LOOKED AT RAND REPORT.
WE LOOKED AT THE WORK THAT
QUALITY COUNTS IS DOING IN TERMS
OF SUPPORTING THE WORKFORCE.
AND ALL IN ALL WE NEEDED TO
START IN TERMS OF IF WE DO NOT
IMPROVE.
THE RATE OF REIMBURSEMENT AND
HOW MUCH WE PAY OUR BRAIN
DEVELOPERS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET FROM HERE TO THERE.
SO THAT'S WE WE REALLY STARTED
IN TERMS OF WITHOUT INCREASING
THE DOLLARS THAT ARE INVESTED.
IN THE PROGRAMS IN THE
PARTICULAR IN THE COMPENSATION.
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
THIS AMAZING WORK WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET VERY FAR.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER MORE WORK
FORCES ARE KERN WORK FORCES
UNDERPAID OVERWORKED AND IN MANY
CASES NOT SUPPORTED.
BY ANY SYSTEM.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IN SOME
CASES WE DO HAVE THE SUPPORT
MECHANISMS BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
TO BE PART.
OF A BIG SYSTEM THEY'RE IN A
CENTER BASED PROGRAM WHEN
THEY'RE PART OF A NONPROFIT.
BUT WITHIN A SYSTEM THAT'S IN
THE CENTER AND DO HAVE RESOURCES.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE CARING.
FOR A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
CHILDREN.
WHAT ABOUT THE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THAT MIGHT BE PART OF
A FAMILY CHILD CARE NETWORK BUT
MIGHT NOT HAVE?
AS MANY SUPPORT IN ONE AREA
VERSUS ANOTHER VERSUS COACHELLA
AS OPPOSED TO FRESNO AS OPPOSED
TO LA AS OPPOSED TO LAKE COUNTY
AT CETERA.
WHAT ABOUT THE WORK FORCE THAT
IS ALL OVER OUR GREAT STATE?
THE DEAL WITH.
CHILDREN WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE WHO
HAVE --
NEEDS IN TERMS OF SPECIAL NEEDS
WHAT ABOUT BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
WHAT ABOUT SECOND LANGUAGE
LEARNING ISSUES.
SO OUR WORK FORCE IS NOT ONLY
DIVERSE IN TERMS OF WHO WE ARE.
BUT THE CHILDREN THAT WE'RE
SERVING AND THE VAST NEEDS THAT
ARE THERE.
WITHIN --
OUR EXISTING SYSTEM WE NEED TO
VALUE WHAT WE DO HAVE.
WHAT WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE IS HOW
IMPORTANT THE EXISTING WORK
FORCE?
THAT WE HAVE AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE TELL THEM HOW IMPORTANT WHAT
A GREAT JOB THEY'VE DONE.
BUT THAT THEY MAY NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
CARE THEMSELVES AND COMPENSATION
THAT WE BELIEVE IS DUE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WORK FORCE THAT IS THERE IS
SUPPORTING THE NEEDS OF THE
FAMILIES WHETHER IT'S IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN THE PARENTS ARE
WORKING.
WHETHER IT'S IN THE DESERT IN A
IN A IN A RURAL AREA OR IN AN
URBAN AREA.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER THAT OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS AN ASSET WHICH WE NEED TO
BUILD UP.
WE HAVE A MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
THAT NEEDS TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
A PRIVATE PUBLIC.
CENTER BASED HOME BASED AND THAT
IT NEEDS TO BE REALLY MADE MORE
ABUNDANT.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER THE CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR OUR EXISTING WORK
FORCE AND TO ATTRACT.
A LOT MORE PEOPLE INTO THE WORK
FORCE AND THE FIRST PLACES TO
BEGIN WITH THAT COMPENSATION.
BUT ALSO WITH IT I'M GOING TO
THE TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S THE
PRE SERVICE ENTITIES WHETHER WE
CHOOSE TO GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHETHER IT'S A RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL THAT SUPPORTS US
BECAUSE WERE ALREADY SERVING
THOSE FAMILIES.
WHETHER IT'S A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WHETHER IT'S THE FIRST
FIVE IN A LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WHETHER IT'S A NONPROFIT.
THAT IS OUT THERE ARE ALREADY
DOING THIS FOR US AND OR A FOUR
YEAR UNIVERSITY BECAUSE SOME OF
OUR WORKFORCE I INDIVIDUALS
CHOOSE TO NOT ONLY GET AN EIGHT
EIGHT AND A B..
EIGHT AND WHAT EVER CHOICES BUT
IT NEEDS TO BE WHERE THEY NEED
AND THE CHOICES THAT INDIVIDUAL
CAN COME ABOUT.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
GIVE ONGOING SUPPORT NO MATTER
WHETHER.
OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
HAVE THEIR EIGHT AND MANY DO.
SOME OF THEM HAVE THEIR BE EIGHT
AND MANY DO BUT IF THEY DON'T
WHAT DO WE DO IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN OUR REGIONS AND
IN OUR STATE TO INSURE.
THAT WE MAINTAIN AND SUSTAIN A
HIGH CALL QUALITY WORK FORCE FOR
INFANTS.
TODDLERS ARE PRESCHOOLS AND
BEYOND BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN DO NEED THAT I'M GOING.
CARE PART UNTIL THEY'RE TWELVE
YEARS OLD AND SO I KNOW THAT
MANY OF THE AUDIENCE THAT OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS ARE.
ARE ALWAYS ADVOCATING FOR FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THE REPORT HAS A LOT MORE.
AND NOW THEY IN A FINANCED IT SO
WILL TRANSFER OVER.
TO TANYA DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING.
YEAH SO AND JUST ONE MORE THING --
THAT SOON I HAD TALKED ABOUT
THIS MORNING AND IT WAS THE FACT
THAT THERE'S SO MANY ENTITIES
OUT THERE.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE BUT WE NEVER
COME TOGETHER.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THIS WHOLE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM IS IS.
IS DISJOINTED.
AND SO UNTIL WE RECOGNIZED AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO COLLABORATE
AND COME TOGETHER AT THE TABLE --
WE'LL STAY DISJOINTED AND WHICH
MEANS THE WORK FORCE WILL NOT
HAVE ROOM TO GROW.
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT SHE JUST
LAID OUT THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
HAVE DISCUSSED WE FELT LIKE THAT
WILL THAT WILL HAPPEN AND THAT
WILL TAKE PLACE.
AND WE FEEL LIKE WE ARE A MODEL
OF WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
WHEN GROUPS FROM EVERY
ORGANIZATION COMES TOGETHER AND
CAN COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS
AND SO --
JUST ADDING THAT LIKE I SAID
WHERE THE OUR FIRST FIVE OR YOUR
UNION -- WE
ALL NEED TO LEARN HOW TO COME IN
AND WORK TOGETHER AND THAT IS
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE THE WORK
FORCE EVEN STRONGER [inaudible]
THE COMMISSION.
PUSH THE BLAME IS COMMISSIONER
MAHDI --
CARING FOR CHILDREN I THINK WE
ALL NOT THINK I ABSOLUTELY NO
THAT WE ALL CARE. FOR TELL TO
EDUCATE CHILDREN AND WE ALL
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATING AND
CARING FOR STUDENTS AND CHILDREN
DO NOT.
IT DOESN'T START ONCE YOU ENTER
KINDERGARTEN.
IT STARTS THE MINUTE A CHILD IS
BORN.
CHILDREN WHO DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO QUALITY CARE BEFORE THEY
ENTER KINDERGARTEN.
ARE AT A TREMENDOUS DISADVANTAGE
AND WILL HAVE TO WORK MANY TIMES
HARDER TO CATCH UP.
IMPROVING IN INCREASING SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE A MUST.
AND THE SERVICES THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE IN PLACE MUST BE EASIER TO
ACCESS.
SYSTEMS MUST BE SIMPLIFIED AND
THE ALIGNMENT IN COORDINATION
BETWEEN VARIOUS AGENCIES AND
PROGRAMS CARING FOR CHILDREN
MUST IMPROVE IF WE ARE TO CLOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS GAP
SO PREVALENT ACROSS OUR NEW
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONWIDE.
SO THIS ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONS HEARING --
RECOMMENDATIONS AIM TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE FOLLOWING AREAS.
BARRIERS TO DISTRICT
PARTICIPATION IN PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS NEED TO BE
MEDICATED.
INCLUDING COORDINATION AND
GREATER ALIGNMENT OF SCHEDULES
FACILITY REGULATIONS AN
APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF DAYS AND
YEAR TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES.
TARGETED SUPPORT PROGRAMS SHOULD
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO CHILDREN
WHO FACE SPECIAL CHALLENGES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE EARLY
ASSESSMENT AND INTERVENTION.
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICT PROGRAMS AND ARE MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEMS MUST BE
STRENGTHENED.
STAFF QUALIFICATIONS RATIOS AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
PRACTICES. FOR CHILDREN BIRTH TO
AGE FIVE SHOULD BE ANALYZED AND
WHERE NECESSARY CHANGE TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN THRIVE.
WE MUST TAKE ADVANTAGE OF STRONG
EXPERTISE ALREADY IN EXISTENCE
THROUGH FIRST FIVE AND HEAD
START IN ORDER TO PROVIDE A MORE
SEAMLESS SERVICE.
THAT ADDRESSES SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL IT NEEDS OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THROUGH WRAPAROUND
SERVICES.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN TRIBAL AREAS HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE.
THAT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS
AND REQUIREMENTS OF ALL COLORS
ARE CULTURALLY RELEVANT.
AND RESPONSIVE AND REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
AND ASSESSMENTS SHOULD BE BUILT
ON THEIR CURRENT STRENGTH.
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR PRE
PRESCHOOL HEAD START AND OTHER
PROGRAMS SHOULD BE EXAMINED TO
INCREASE ACCESS.
AND THERE IS TREMENDOUS NEED TO
COLLABORATE WITH BUSINESS AND
ENCOURAGE PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES.
I TO SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
DEVELOP FAMILY FRIENDLY
WORKPLACES.
REGIONAL EFFORTS NEED TO INCLUDE
LOCAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
IDENTIFY EQUITY GAPS SUPPORT
LOCAL INNOVATION.
COORDINATE LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
AND EVALUATE LOCAL EFFORTS.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE MUST
COORDINATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
INTEGRATED BIRTH TO FIVE SYSTEM
STATEWIDE.
THAT ADDRESSES THE MULTIPLE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES USING
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE MODELS.
WORKING IN SILOS HAS NOT AND
WILL NOT WORK.
WE MUST REACH ACROSS SYSTEMS AND
OVERCOME TRADITIONAL DIVISIONS.
AND AREAS TO BETTER SERVE OUR
CHILDREN.
IT TAKES ALL OF US AND OUR
COORDINATED AND ALIGNED EFFORTS
TO REACH OUR GOAL OF MAKING SURE
ALL CHILDREN.
HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE FROM
BIRTH AND ALL THE WAY UP TO
COLLEGE AND BEYOND.
IT TAKES COLLECTIVE WILL. TO
COLLABORATE IN ORDER TO CHANGE
THINGS AND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
EXPECT US TO HAVE THE COLLECTIVE
WILL AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT BY THEM.
AND MY HOPE IS THAT WHEN WE ARE
DONE.
IT DOES THIS.
DOES NOT SAY WAITING TO BE SEEN.
AND DEMAND TO BE HEARD THAT YOU
ARE SEEING AND YOU ARE HER.
OKAY SO THERE ARE THREE SECTIONS
LEFT TO GO.
AND BETWEEN DOCTOR ACROSS CAN I
WE ARE GOING TO ADDRESS.
THOSE THREE SECTIONS SO I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT.
SYSTEMS INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPLYING
AND FACILITIES I'M GOING TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT GOVERNANCE
AND ADMINISTRATION FINANCING.
AND THEN DOCTOR MCCROSKEY IS
GOING TO BRING IT ON HOME
TALKING ABOUT INTEGRATED DATA
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE THOUGHT THAT.
IT MADE SENSE TO END.
ON OKAY SO.
I SOME OF WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY
IS PROBABLY A REPEAT OF WHAT
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD.
BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT SINCE
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR FORTY
TWO YEARS.
WHICH MAKES ME ONE OF THE SENIOR
CITIZEN ASSEMBLY REALLY
CHILDHOOD FIELD --
HI.
I'M GONNA GO REPEAT THESE THINGS
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A OF A LONG
TIME COMING MY MOTHER WOULD BE
SO PROUD.
SO.
ARE IN THE SYSTEMS
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPLY AND
FACILITIES --
WE START BY TALKING ABOUT THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WE HAVE TO
APPLY EQUITY LENDS TO IT.
THAT MEANS THAT THE PLANNING THE
EVALUATION IN EVERY ASPECT OF
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION.
WE HAVE TO AND YOU'VE HEARD THIS
BEFORE YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE FROM ONE OF COMPLIANCE
TO ONE OF FAMILY AND CHILD
SUPPORT.
THIS IS LIKE NO SMALL FEAT THIS
IS REALLY A MAJOR PIECE BECAUSE
FOR THE LAST --
I DON'T KNOW TWO DOZEN YEARS
WE'VE BEEN REALLY LOOKED AT
ABOUT.
COMPLIANCE AND LOOKED AT ABOUT
FRAUD AND NOW WE REALLY NEED TO
TALK ABOUT SUPPORTING CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED
TO CREATE INTER AGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD ADVISORY COUNCIL THAT
MAKES UP ALL THE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ADVICE ON EARLY CHILDHOOD --
WE NEED TO ELEVATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
RESPONSIBILITY --
YOU HEARD ABOUT PARENTS AND ALSO
WORKFORCE COUNCILS TO FEED INTO
THIS EARLY CHILDHOOD ADVISORY
COUNCIL.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE REALISTIC FEES THAT PARENTS
CAN PAY.
ARE YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT AND WE NEED TO REMOVE THE
UNNECESSARY COMPLEX CONTRACTS
AND CONTRACTING.
PROCESS IS THAT US AGENCIES
ADMINISTER AS WELL AS PARENTS
HAVE TO DEAL WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
WE HAVE TO REVIEW LICENSING STAY.
THOSE WITH QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS.
WERE RECOMMENDING --
WE CONVENE A DISASTER RECOVERY
TASK FORCE THAT WOULD BUILD ON
THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN PLAN
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW PROVIDERS
DON'T HAVE.
DISASTER RECOVERY PLANS AND
REALLY NEED ONE ESPECIALLY IN
THIS LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WERE
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DISASTER
EVERY COUPLE OF MONTHS.
WHERE --
RECOMMENDING THAT WE ADOPT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM
WORKING GROUP'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND IN ADDITION RATE SHOULD
ALLOW FOR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
AND FOR BENEFITS PACKAGES --
WE NEED TO DEVELOP NEW
FACILITIES BASED ON EMERGING
NEEDS INCLUDING LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES.
AND WE SHOULD INCLUDE HEAD START
AND STATE PLANNING TO GET TO
FULL DAY FULL YEAR THROUGH OUR
HEAD START PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
THROUGH OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND TRANSFER FUNDS FROM THE
CURRENT REVOLVING LOAN FUND TO
THE NEWS FACILITIES PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING.
THAT WOULD BE A GRANT PROGRAM
AND NOT A A BORROWING FROM.
IN TERMS OF GOVERNANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION.
WE STRONGLY FEEL THAT WE HAVE TO
BUILD ON A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NATURE OF
CHILD CARE.
AND EARLY CHILDHOOD AND THAT
THERE SHOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES FOR GOVERNANCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF FINANCING.
THERE SHOULD BE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SETTINGS THAT MEET FAMILY NEEDS
AND OUR HIGH QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE.
THAT'S TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE WELL
COMPENSATED A PROFESSIONALLY
SUPPORTED DIVERSE WORK FORCE.
IN SUPPORT FOR NECESSARY
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE'RE NOT RECOMMENDING THAT
THERE BE ANY A REDUCTION OF
CURRENT FUNDING FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE PROMISES THAT
WE MADE DEPARTMENT LIKE DAY. ONE
NINETY EIGHT IN THAT WE FEEL THE
CHILD CARE WORKERS AND PROVIDER
SHOULD NOT FINANCE THROUGH THEIR
LOW WAGES AND THEIR LACK OF
BENEFITS THE FEEL THAT THEY
SHOULD BE COMPENSATED THE WAY
THAT EVERYBODY ELSE'S COMPENSATE.
WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING THAT IN
ORDER TO GET TO A 100% OF
FUNDING FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WE'LL LIMóN AT THE CAP ON
TAXABLE WAGES OF A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND AND SIXTY
SEVEN SO THAT.
EVERYBODY PAYS TOWARDS MAKING
SURE THAT THE YOUNGEST CHILDREN
HAVE THEIR PARENTS. FOR THOSE IN
CRITICAL BONDING TIMES THEN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAXIMIZING
FEDERAL DRAWDOWNS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ENSURING THAT ALL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT MONEY GOES
TO SERVE THOSE CHILDREN WHO DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL.
IN SO.
THERE'S A LOT MORE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I THOUGHT I
WOULD JUST PULL OUT THOSE IS IS
BEING SOME THAT THAT I THOUGHT
TO BE PARTICULARLY USEFUL.
AND THEN OVERVIEW FOR CLEAN UP
THEIR ACT.
THANK YOU. FOR A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGE TRYING TO SAY ALL OF
THIS IN A SHORT TIME AND YOU CAN
HELP BUT WE REALLY WANT TO GET
TO YOU -- SO
IN TERMS OF THE DATA THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF DATA.
IS [inaudible]
NOT EVEN BEGINNING TO BE
ADEQUATE TO SUPPORT THIS
COMPLICATED SYSTEM IT'S NOT THAT
WE DON'T COLLECT A LOT OF DATA
WE COLLECT A LOT OF DATA AS
ANYBODY WHO'S A PROVIDER KNOWS
AND IS ANYBODY WHO'S A PARENT
KNOWS.
THERE'S AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
FORM FILLING OUT AND FORM RE
COMPLETION AND RE AND CETERA
IT'S NOT ALL DATA THAT'S
ACTUALLY USED. FOR ON GOING
IMPROVEMENT OF THE SYSTEM IT'S
BEEN AS AS THAT NUMBER VESTED
SAID SEVERAL TIMES COMPLIANCE
ORIENTED NOT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
ORIENTED.
AND WE ALL NEED TO BAND TOGETHER.
DATA CAN BE REALLY IT HELPFUL
THE DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
DIRECTLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FROM
PROGRAMS BUT ALSO COORDINATING
THAT DATA WITH OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE COLLECTING DATA SO WHERE.
FOR JUST FOR EXAMPLE PROJECTING
OUR CHILD POPULATION SO WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE PLANNING
FOR INTO THE FUTURE THERE ARE A
LOT OF PIECES OF DATA THAT WE
JUST HAVEN'T COORDINATED HERE --
THE THE TRANSPARENCY OF THE
SYSTEM IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
TRANSPARENT TO THOSE OF US WHO
WORK IN IT BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT TRANSPARENT TO PARENTS
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
CARE AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN THEIR AREA.
AND TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC
THIS IS.
I WORK A LOT OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES SYSTEMS AND THIS IS ONE
OF THE MOST COMPLICATED. TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND --
THE INTEGRATION OF DATA IS ALSO
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
FAMILIES NEED A LOT OF HELP AND
SUPPORT ALONG THE WAY AT
DIFFERENT POINTS IN TIME SO
MAKING SURE WE COULD SHARE DATA.
THAT REALLY SUPPORTS THOSE NEEDS
SO WHERE FINANCING THEM
APPROPRIATELY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
CAN AND THE LAST THING I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ALL THE WE
REFERRED TO IT IS THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY IT'S SUCH A
COMPLICATED SYSTEM.
IS THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD A CORD
LEVEL AND SO ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS HAS TO
DO WITH --
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL THAT
WOULD PULL TOGETHER THE PLAYERS
FOR MULTIPLE PARTS OF THIS
SYSTEM TO ADVISE THE GOVERNOR OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC --
SO WE CAN HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PLACE WHICH IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT OVERSIGHT WHICH IS REALLY
THINKING ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
WHICH IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT IN WHICH IS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT.
HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE --
THERE ARE TWO KEY SETS OF
PLAYERS HIS VOICE IS HAVE TO BE
FRONT AND CENTER ON THEM.
THE PARENTS THROUGH A PARENT
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND THE WORK
FORCE TO A WORKFORCE BUT AS YOU
CANCEL AND RATHER THAN SAYING
LET'S POINT ONE PARENT OR TWO
PARENTS LET'S POINT ONE PROVIDER
TO PROVIDERS.
WE REALLY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT EACH GROUP HAVE ITS OWN
COUNCIL.
WITH SUPPORT AND WITH THREE
SOURCES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING SO THAT THEY THEY
GET THE CHANCE TO WORK THROUGH
IDEAS AND AND BRING THEM FORWARD
TO THIS.
OVERALL POLICY COUNCIL THE THE
LEADERSHIP OBVIOUSLY TO FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM THE GOVERNOR
FROM KEY ORGANIZATIONS --
FIRST FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM ALL OF
THAT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT.
TO AND SO WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING THAT WE ESTABLISH
AN OFFICE FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDES A
REALLY STRONG INTER AGENCY WORK
GROUP.
THAT THE ABILITY OF STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK TOGETHER IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT SO IS
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S TO WORK WITH
OUTSIDE EXTERNAL ENTITIES.
WHO CAN PROVIDE RESOURCES THE
STAFF AND WE WON'T GET IT DONE --
AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS WORKED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL LITTLE TINY
LOCALITY NAMED LOS ANGELES
KILLING FOR A LAST TWENTY YEARS
ON THIS WE'RE TRYING REALLY HARD
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND THEY
KNOW PEOPLE ARE AND OTHER
REGIONS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT WITHOUT CLARITY FROM THE
STATE LEVEL IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO GET IT DONE AND SO
LIKE ALL THE OTHER COMMISSIONERS
WE ARE JUST INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
TO THE ASSEMBLY --
FOR LOOK FOR LETTING US
PLAINTIFF OKAY TODAY.
ALSO FOR LETTING US LEARN AND
WORK WITH YOU OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND IT COULD NOT BE MORE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY THANK YOU WHAT WE KNOW.
THIS IS YOUR LIFE'S WORK SO
THANKS. FOR ALLOWING US TO BE
PART OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE EXPERTISE AND TIME.
YOU HIGHLY COMPENSATED
COMMISSIONERS PUT INTO.
INTO EVER --
BEFORE WE GET TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION --
ANY COMMISSIONS AT SOME COMMENTS
COMMISSIONER IGNATIUS.
I'M SORRY JUST REALLY QUICKLY --
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE JUST
HOW IMPORTANT THE FINANCING
PIECES AND AND THE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAD THAT WE WE NEED REVENUES
WE NEED MORE THAN ONE TIME
FUNDING SOLUTIONS THAT.
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO REQUIRE
ROBUST --
CONVERSATION AROUND THAT AND THE
REASON OUR POINT THAT OUT IS
BECAUSE SOMETHING OR MCCARTY YOU
JUST GAVE US A REALLY LIKE HIGH
NOTE ABOUT THE YOU KNOW SOME
GOOD NEWS OUT OF WASHINGTON DC.
BUT THAT ONE BILLION COMES AT
THE EXPENSE OF MAKING CUTS TO
MEDICARE AL AND HOUSING AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND THAT'S WHAT WE WE
HAVE TO GET AWAY FROM.
YOU KNOW TAKING FUNDING FROM ONE
PROGRAM THE FAMILIES REALLY NEED
TO TO PROVIDE FOR SOMETHING ELSE
FAMILIES REALLY NEEDS OF REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
AN OPTION SO I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT.
COLLEGES FOR SORRY THE GOOD
THAT'S OKAY WELL CONGRESS SAID
THAT BUDGETS DEAD ON ARRIVAL SO
WE'LL TAKE THE TAKE THE GOOD
NEWS IS.
IN THE BUDGET AND AND RE
APPROPRIATE THE OTHER STUFF.
YES --
COMMISSION OWNIK I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
NANCY STROLL KILL GROUND AND
STACY RIORDAN. FOR KEEPING US
ALL TOGETHER AND MAKING SURE
THAT ALL THE GREAT IDEAS THAT WE
THREW OUT THERE GOT PUT TO PAPER
AND ALSO.
HE NOW SEES A CHRISTIAN
SCHUMACHER DID --
WE WOULD NOT BE WHERE WE ARE
WITHOUT WITHOUT THOSE FOUR
MINUTES.
YES WELL SAID.
AND EVERYBODY THAT PARTICIPATED
ON THE PANELS THROUGHOUT THIS
SEVEN HEARINGS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THEY WERE ALL LOOKS VERY WELL
PREPARED --
HELPED US UNDERSTAND.
NO THE ISSUES FROM THE FROM THE
FORTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL --
JUST FROM YOU KNOW I REMEMBER
PARENTS COMING UP AT SOME OF
THOSE HEARINGS JUST SHARING
THEIR PERSPECTIVES WHICH ENABLE
US TO REALLY UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THEM.
PROGRAMS AND THE LACK OF SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES AND KIDS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA --
SO SO WITH THAT WE WANT TO BEGIN
WITH THAT PUBLIC COMMENT TO ME
BECAUSE START MAKING WITH THIS
SIDE AND AS YOU START COMING UP.
WE DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS
NOT THE END --
WE DO ENCOURAGE THAT PUBLIC TO
SUBMIT COMMENTS --
IN WRITING.
YOU EMAIL THEM TO THAT'S TO US
AND WE WILL INCORPORATE THOSE IN
OUR FINAL REPORT AND THE FINAL
REPORT WILL DO JUST WHAT YOU
SAID.
COMMISSIONER NIECES AS LOOK AT
THE TOTALITY OF OF OF THESE.
IDEAS -- PUT
IN PLACE A COST ESTIMATES
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS PILOT PEOPLE
OUT THERE SAYING WELL THIS IS
FABULOUS AMAZING WHAT IS THIS
COSTS AND SO WE'RE NOT QUITE TO
THAT POINT YET.
AND WE DO HAVE SOME IDEAS AS FAR
AS HOW WE GET FINANCE THIS IN
CALIFORNIA --
AS WELL.
SO I'M GONNA WE'RE GONNA ASK
EACH -- EACH
PARTICIPANT TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO ROUGHLY A MINUTE.
IF YOU CUT.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS TONY ISAAC
SOMEONE I THINK THIS SOMEONE
MEMBERS AND THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONERS I AM FROM PEACH
WERE EARLY CHILDHOOD HIGHER
EDUCATION COLLABORATIVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT --
EARLY CHILDHOOD AND EARLY YOU
SEE FACULTY FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE CS USE UC'S AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND WE WANNA --
THANK THE COMMISSIONERS PHAM
DEEPLY FOR THIS HOLISTIC
APPROACH --
AND LISTENING TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS AS YOU CREATED THE
PRINCIPLES AND DRAFT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REALLY MAKE
SURE YOU'RE MEETING THE NEEDS OF
OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND AS WELL AS TO
ADDRESS.
THE NEEDS OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
WORK FOR SAY THAT WE RECOGNIZE
IT IN THE WORK FORCE OF QUALITY
SECTION THE IMPORTANCE THAT
COMPETENCY BASED ASSESSMENT
SHOULD BE CREATED FOR ALL
POSITIONS.
INCLUDING TEACHERS COACHES
ADMINISTRATORS.
AND CENTER DIRECTORS WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU --
VALUE THE INVESTMENT IN
PROVIDING OUR RESOURCES FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR DIVERSE WORKFORCE.
AND INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR
TUITION BOOKS FEES AS WELL AS
THE IMPORTANCE FOR PROFESSIONAL
GROWTH ADVISORS AND EASY
SPECIFIC OUR COLLEGE CAREER
COUNSELORS.
AND FINALLY WE JUST WANT TO URGE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY
COUNCIL THAT --
HIGHER EDUCATION IS AT THE TABLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I AM DOT TO MARTINE
JAY GUMM ALSO REPRESENTATIVE OF
PEACH.
AND SERVE AS A PRESS MEDICATION
AT PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
AND PSYCHOLOGY MY DOCTOR IS IN
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNING AND I
CHILDHOOD POLICY PEOPLE AND
PROCESSES.
AND WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE AT
PEACH YOUR SUPPORT FOR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AS NOTED IN THE REPORT.
WE AT PEACH THANK THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY IN EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND EQUITY IN EASY WORKFORCE
COMPETENCY BASED.
PREPARATION IN SERVICE TRAINING
ASSESSMENT AND COMMENSURATE CON
COMPENSATION.
I REFERS SPECIFICALLY TO THE REC
MEN EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
DEEPLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES SPECIAL HEALTHCARE
NEEDS AND WE ALSO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT FOR THE DEVELOPMENT AND
MODIFICATION.
OF ECP SPECIFIC HIGHER EDUCATION
GRADUATE PROGRAMS TO ALIGN WITH
DECISION. TO INCREASE OUR
STATE'S CAPACITY TO PREPARE EAZY
E. SPECIFIC HIGHER EDUCATION
FACULTY AT MOST OF AND DOCTORAL
LEVELS.
GRADUATES WHO WILL SERVE AS EASY
E. FACULTY INTO YEAR FAURIA AND
BEYOND HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY FOR IN YOUR
FOR FROM THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER.
I WANT TO JUST THANK ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATORS THE STAFF --
WHO DID SO MUCH WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE?
APPROPRIATELY GROUNDED IN THE
EXPERIENCE THAT'S AVAILABLE IN
THE WIDER CHILD CARE COMMUNITY
AND IS FOCUSED ON WHAT PERRANCE --
AS EXPERTS AND THE PROVIDERS WHO
PROVIDE THE CARE TO OUR CHILDREN
BRING TO THIS CONVERSATION AND
THAT REALITY BASED --
INFORMATION AND INPUT IS WHAT
MAKES YOUR RECOMMENDATION SO
STRONG.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT --
THIS REPORT IS TOO IMPORTANT TO
GET SHELVED IN A IN A DESK
SOMEWHERE.
AND WE WE WANT TO THANK YOU BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO SAY YOUR WORK IS
NOT DONE.
THAT -- THIS
IS JUST THE BEGINNING THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS BECOME THE
FOUNDATIONAL SET OF POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT INFORM.
OUR SYSTEM AND RECOMMEND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE FUTURE --
STRENGTHS IN OUR SYSTEMS.
AND THAT'S WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS THE REPORT THAT IS
THE BLUEPRINT FOR THE FUTURE.
AND WE WILL JOIN YOU IN MAP BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE YOUR WORK AS
WELL I WANT TO FOCUS ON JUST ONE
AREA WHICH IS --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WITH RESPECT
TO A PARTICULAR CHILDREN LIVING
IN POVERTY AND I I APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO CALLING
OUT.
THAT THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON FIRST --
AND NOT AS PART OF OUR TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM.
AND WHEN WE TARGET CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES MOST IN NEED THE ONE
PROGRAM THAT WE WANT TO REALLY
LOOK AT IS THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM
WHERE EVERYONE BY DEFINITION IS
LIVING AT BEST AT 50% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
NOT THE SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY
MEASURE IN CALIFORNIA BUT THAT --
THAT VERY LOW LEVEL NATION OF
TWELVE MONTHS OF STABLE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION IS SO
IMPORTANT --
BECAUSE IF ANYBODY NEEDS
STABILITY ITS CHILDREN WHO ARE
LIVING IN SUCH DEEP POVERTY.
AND THAT ALSO WILL DO WONDERS TO
MEETING YOUR OTHER GOAL WHICH
YOU MENTIONED WHICH IS TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE OF COMPLIANCE TO ONE
OF FAMILY WELL BEING AND SUPPORT
FOR CHILDREN'S EARLY
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS.
IN ADDITION TO STABLE CHILD CARE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
SEAMLESS AND SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SYSTEMS
CHANGE INCLUDE.
ONLINE ACCESS TO THE DATA NEEDED
TO KEEP FAMILIES AND ROLLED AND
PARTICIPATING SEAMLESS
TRANSITIONS.
MAKING SURE THAT FAMILIES WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN OTHER VERY --
WORTHY PROGRAMS WHETHER IT'S
HEAD START OR STATE PRESCHOOL
ARE STILL ALLOWED ACCESS TO THE
CAL WORKS CHILDCARE PROGRAMS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
AREN'T THESE CONSTANT
INTERRUPTIONS --
I THINK THAT THE REPORTS THAT
WAS -- DONE
WHAT WAITING TO BE.
SEEN DEMANDING TO BE HEARD
PROBLEMS AND I URGE YOU TO ADOPT
THOSE CHANGES AS WELL MOSTLY I
WANT TO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTOPHER MIRACLE
HEAD START CALIFORNIA FIRST ONE
I THINK THE COMMISSION THIS IS A
BOLD.
COMPREHENSIVE AND BALANCED
ASSESSMENT OF A VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEM AND I THINK IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY ACHIEVEMENT.
I ONLY WANT TO POINT OUT ONE
SMALL IDEA.
IN THE SECTION COMPENSATION
THERE'S A STATEMENT REGARDING --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR DIRECT
COMPENSATION.
OUR FOR LICENSED PROGRAMS
RECEIVING STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
FUNDS AND I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT MANY OF OUR HEAD START
PROGRAMS --
ARE NEITHER IN AND OUT IN AN
ALLEY A AND MAY NOT HAVE A STATE
CONTRACT AND SO THINKING ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT COMPENSATE
HOWEVER WE INVEST IN
COMPENSATION FOR THE WORK FORCE.
THAT IT ADDRESSES EITHER --
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL FUND
SUPPORT OR APPROACHING IT FROM --
THE LANGUAGE OF ALL PROGRAMS
PROVIDING SUBSPACE CARE.
HAVING SAID THAT AGAIN WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS FOR PORT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE VERY
CHALLENGING IDEA OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO FIND THIS REPORT.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KRISTIN POWER THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WE APPRECIATE THE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO INVESTING IN
CHILDREN BY PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY ASSESSABLE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IN PARTICULAR WE SUPPORT A
NUMBER OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
DRIVE YOUR ATTENTION THREE AND
SEVEN THE EXPANSION OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD.
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE --
WE WOULD RECOMMEND ON FOR F. ONE
THE STREAMLINING OF THE
PUBLICATION OF CURRENT EDUCATOR
IN CARE GIVER COMPETENCIES TO
FOCUS ON ESSENTIAL ADULT
PRACTICES IMPROVE.
CHILD OUTCOMES WE WOULD SUGGEST
INCORPORATING TROUT.
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING INTO
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO ENSURE
THAT THAT TRAINING --
INCLUDES THOSE TRAUMA INFORMED
PRACTICES THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
COMMISSIONERS FOR RECOGNIZING
AND EMPHASIZING FACILITIES
INVESTMENTS AS A VITAL PRIORITY
IN SECTION SEVEN ARE YOUR DRAFT
REPORT.
AND FOR RECOMMENDING GRANTS TO
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS SO THAT WE
CAN ACQUIRE AND TRANSFORM NEW
AND EXISTING FACILITIES FOR
GREATER ACCESS TO EASY QUALITY
EASY PROGRAMS.
MY NAME IS THE LOOK AT A YOUNG
THE VP OF OPERATIONS FOR MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD CENTERS.
A. OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CELEBRATING SIXTY
YEARS OF PROVIDING --
EMPOWERING CULTURALLY ADEQUATE --
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND SOCIAL
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME SENIORS
YOUTH CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT SAN FRANCISCO.
I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF ESCO WHO ARE
PROVIDING WHO ARE FACED.
WITH THE ONGOING CHALLENGER
PROVIDING QUALITY AFFORDABLE
CARE TO OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
AND ONE OF THE STATE'S HIGHEST
COST --
COUNTIES.
THE FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE
STRUGGLE TO A FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN THE BAY AREA A
STRUGGLE THAT IS FELT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
OUR CENTERS PROVIDE A RELIEF TO
WORKING FAMILIES WE ARE A VITAL
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND AN INVALUABLE RESOURCE TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE ON A DAILY BASIS.
WE STILL HAVE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN ON LENGTHY WAIT LIST
WHO NEED AND DESERVE ACCESS TO
THE QUALITY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CENTERS PROVIDE BUT THEY WERE
UNABLE TO OFFER DUE TO THE LACK
OF CURRENT PHYSICAL SPACE IN OUR
INABILITY TO EXPAND BECAUSE OF
THE COST OF UP COST PROHIBITIVE
NATURE.
OF ESTABLISHING OR EXPANDING NEW
CENTERS AND THE LIMITED FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THERE ARE FOR
FACILITIES WITHOUT THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS FAR TOO
MANY OF CHILDREN --
CALIFORNIA'S MOST WONDERFUL
CHILDREN ARE LEFT WITHOUT ACCESS
TO QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES EXACERBATING
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY A PERPETUATE
THE READING THIS GAP AND THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
I ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP FOR YOUR VISION AND
FOR RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF THESE INVESTMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CONDITIONS TO IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
REFERRAL NETWORK.
TODAY MY CHILD HAD TO ACCOMPANY
ME AGAIN BECAUSE ON THURSDAY
NIGHT I SAID --
SLEEP THERE'S NO SCHOOL ON
MONDAY AS A TEACHER WORK DAY BUT
IT'S NOT LOST ON ME THE
PRIVILEGE THAT I HAVE AND HAVE
HAD THROUGHOUT HER LIFE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST HEARING
MACY'S SAT THROUGH.
IN HER LIFE --
BECAUSE OF NO SCHOOL OR LACK OF
CHILD CARE IN A PARTICULAR DAY
THAT I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
BRINGING HER WITH ME.
AND THAT SO MANY PARENTS DON'T
HAVE THAT THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN A
DAY THAT EITHER THEY TOOK OFF
WITH NO PAY --
WITH THE WITH THAT FEAR --
HAD TO GO THROUGH THAT.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU IRA IRA HAVE VERY ROSE
COLORED GLASSES AND AS YOU CAN
SEE THE SPARKLES ON TOP --
AND SO I LOVE THIS REPORT I FELT
SO LIKE INSPIRED INSPIRED BY IT
AND I I APPRECIATE THAT --
BOLD PROPOSALS THAT ARE THERE.
AND I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT THEIR
HEART THAT WE CAN DO THIS I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE --
YOUR RECOGNITION OF OF THE
RACIST ROOTS OF CHILD CARE IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY FROM --
IF THE TIME OF SLAVERY AND
ENSLAVED AFRICANS TAKING CARE.
OF THEIR SLAVE OWNERS TO MODERN
TIMES TODAY WHERE MOST CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE LOW INCOME
WOMEN OF COLOR.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT THE ROLE THAT
IMPLICIT BIAS.
PLAYS IN THE LACK OF RESPECT FOR
PARENTS WHO JUST NEED AND WANT
TO GO TO WORK OR SCHOOL OR HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN IN QUALITY.
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS FROM THE
START AND HAVE THE SAME CHANCE
THAT OTHER PARENTS HAVE --
I'D LIKE YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE FACT AT
AS TYING IT COMMISSIONER.
SORRY MAKE MILLION SAID EARLIER
SHE ALLUDED TO THAT WE REALLY
HAVE THE POOR SUBSIDIZING THE
POOR WE HAVE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR PROVIDERS.
TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN AND WHEN
THEY TO HAVE TO DEPEND ON THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET AND THEY TOO
ARE DISRESPECTED WHEN THEY GO TO
GET HELP AS WELL.
TIM THAT PARENT WHO'S FROM
HANFORD AND FROM HIM --
AS AN ELIGIBILITY WORKER KNOWING.
AND HAVING EMPATHY ON THAT OTHER
SIDE AS SHE'S HELPING OTHER
FAMILIES BUT THAT IS STILL LOST
AMONG MANY FOLKS WHO ARE HELPING
PEOPLE.
AND THEN FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
LIFT INDICATIONS FROM THE PARENT
VOICES.
FOCUS GROUPS --
THAT WE FOCUS ON AS WELL AS THE
NETWORK BECAUSE OF OUR OUR
UNDYING COMMITMENT TO FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND FAMILY
FRIENDLY NEIGHBORS AND THAT IS
THEY ARE --
THE MOST LIKELY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE DURING
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS.
THEY ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE CARE FOR FAMILIES WHO
HAVE NOT PREDICTABLE SCHEDULES.
THEY ARE MOST LIKELY AS AGAIN TO
SUBSIDIZE --
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR BY
HAVING A LOWER AND COST OF CARE
AND CHARGING LAST FOR FAMILIES
TO THEIR MOST AFFORDABLE.
AND SO THEREBY GIVING THEMSELVES
VERY LOW INCOME --
THESE PROVIDERS ARE SUBSIDY
SYSTEM INSTEAD OF TWO DISTANT.
DISTANT. TO NOT PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. FOR PROVIDERS TO TO
ACCEPT CHILDREN AND FROM
FAMILIES TO REQUIRE SUBSIDY
BECAUSE THEY NEVER KNOW THEY
CAN'T DEPEND ON HOW MUCH THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PAID FROM ONE MONTH
TO ANOTHER.
CAN YOU WRAP UP PLEASE YEAH.
I TALK TOO MUCH --
AND OKAY THAT'S IT THANK YOU
AGAIN SO MUCH THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN MORE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SPEAK SO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS.
TO AT THE HOPEFULLY UNDER TWO
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERY CHILD
DESERVES TO GROW UP IN A LOVING
WARM ENVIRONMENT AND EVERY
PARENT DESERVES TO GO TO WORK
WITH THEIR MIND AT EASE THAT
THEIR CHILD IS BEING CARED FOR
IN A SAFE.
PLACE MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
AT THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER.
I WANTED TO OFFER COMMENTS ON
ADDRESSING THE AVAILABILITY OF
CHILDCARE AND I ALSO WANTED TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR GREAT
ROBUST WORK.
ON AS WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
REASONS CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA
THE LOW WAGES THE COST OF LIVING.
AND MY FAITH COMMENTS FOCUS ON
THE TO SPECIFIC REGULATORY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ADD TO THE
MANY GREAT RECOMMENDATIONS
ALREADY IN THE REPORT --
AS WE KNOW THERE'S ONLY --
23% OF WORKING PARENTS STATEWIDE
HAVE ACCESS TO CHILDCARE.
AND MY COMMENTS FOCUS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF FAMILY CHILD
CARE WHICH IS PARTICULARLY IN
DIRE NEED FOR THE REASONS THAT
KEY SHOULD JUST SPOKE BEFORE ME
ABOUT.
THEY ALSO OFFER THE CULTURE ONLY
QUICK STICK NEEDS THAT MANY
FAMILIES NEED AND MANY OF THE
WOMEN TAKING CARE OF WE HE
CONSTANTLY AT THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER THAT FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN.
AND CARE FOR MORE CHILDREN
BECAUSE A VERY BURDENSOME AND
EXPENSIVE LOCAL --
FEES AND REQUIREMENTS THESE
WOMEN ON AVERAGE MAKE ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR AND THEY'RE BEING
CHARGED THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
UNNECESSARY FEES.
I'M SO WE URGE THE COMMISSION TO
SUPPORT STATEWIDE POLICIES THAT
BREAK DOWN THESE BARRIERS AND
UNNECESSARY RED TAPE.
AND THERE'S A GREAT BILL SB TWO
THREE FOUR WE URGE THE
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL BEING AUTHORED BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
WE ALSO OFFER THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT ON FOSTER PARENTS WHO WANT
TO PROVIDE CHILDCARE FOR OTHER
FOSTER PARENTS ARE RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS IS ALSO ANOTHER POTENTIAL
SOURCE OF CHILD CARE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN FOSTER PARENTS
NEED CHILD RIGHT AWAY IN AN
EMERGENCY AND DON'T HAVE TIME TO
WAIT FOR THEIR PROVIDER TO BE
TRUST LINE CHECK SO WE URGE THE
COMMISSION. TO ENSURE THAT THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR FOSTER
PARENTS MEET THE RECOMMENDED --
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS FOR TRUST
LINE AND ALSO COORDINATE WITH
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES TO
INCREASE THAT POOL OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ON I AM
COMMUNITIES FOR EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA --
WE WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT A
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK IN CREATING SUCH
A VALUABLE POLICY ROAD MAP TO
HELP CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES --
IT'S GREAT TO SEE SUCH A STRONG
EMPHASIS IN THE DRAFT REPORT
THIS IS THE ON THE REPORT ON
INVESTING IN OUR EARLY LEARNING
WORK FORCE WE KNOW THIS IS KEY
TO BUILDING A HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SOME KEY WORK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EARLY EDGE
ON THAT REALLY STOOD OUT TO US
INCLUDE ACHIEVING PAY PARITY
BETWEEN EARLY LEARNING EDUCATORS
IN K. TWELVE TEACHERS.
MOVING TOWARD A COMPETENCY BASED
PER IN WHICH EARLY LEARNING
TEACHERS WILL DEVELOP AND
DEMONSTRATE SPECIFIC
COMPETENCIES.
AND INVESTING IN A RANGE OF
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORTS TO HELP
OUR EARLY LEARNING TEACHERS IN
ALL SETTINGS GET THE TRAINING
AND EDUCATION THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR JOB WELL.
INCLUDING TRAINING ON HOW TO
SUPPORT OUR DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNER CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION FOR
TAKING A STRONG ASSET BASED
APPROACH. TO OUR DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNER CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES RECOGNIZING THAT THEIR
LINGUISTIC CULTURAL AND
INTELLECTUAL ASSETS CONTRIBUTE
TO THE RICH DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN PARTICULAR EARLY AGE
APPRECIATES THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE REPORT AROUND
ESTABLISHING EVIDENCE BASED
INSTRUCTIONAL APPROACHES FOR
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS THE
PROMOTE HOME LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT.
AND EMPHASIZE BILINGUALISM AND
BY LITERACY.
AND EXPANDING INVESTMENT INTO A
LANGUAGE LEARNER TRAINING AND
SUPPORT TO ACCOMMODATE THE
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY
EARLY LEARNING TEACHERS AND THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THEY SERVE.
THE EARLY LEARNING FEEL NEEDS TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON DEFINING THE
QUALIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE EARLY LEARNING WORK FORCE
FROM BIRTH TO AGE FIVE IN ALL
PROGRAMS ONCE WE DEFINE THE
QUALIFICATIONS CALIFORNIA HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A LEADER
NATION WIDE.
IN CREATING A COMPETENCY BASED
QUALIFICATION AND CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM THAT ENSURES ALL CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
LEARNING AT EVERY AGE.
WE NOW HAVE A GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE THAT VALUE IN
SUPPORT EARLY LEARNING
INITIATIVES SO WE HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
REFORM CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM SO THAT EVERY
TEACHER AND EVERY CHILD HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MICHELLE STORE
PARVIN SKI FROM CANANGA WHICH IS
AN EARLY LEARNING ORGANIZATION
IN THE BAY AREA.
I REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMISSION FOR THIS WONDERFUL
DRAFT REPORT AND ESPECIALLY --
FOR CENTERING THE EXPERIENCES IN
THE EXPERTISE OF PARENTS AND
TEACHERS --
WHO WE KNOW HAVE SO MUCH TO
SHARE ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO DEVELOP A HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING SYSTEM --
WE HAD KIDDING --
HAD A PARENTS THAT CAME UP --
FOR RECENT HEARING THAT --
HELD WHO HIGHLIGHTED THE VALUE
THAT THEY SAW FROM EARLY
EDUCATION IN PRESCHOOL --
IN PREPARING THEIR CHILDREN WITH
THE SOCIAL SKILLS IN THE EARLY
LITERACY AND LANGUAGE SKILLS
THAT THEY NEEDED THEY KNEW --
WERE NECESSARY FOR THEIR KIDS TO
BE READY FOR KINDERGARTEN AND TO
THRIVE --
FOR THE REST OF THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE AND SO THAT SO CREEK
CRITICAL I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO THINGS ARE OUT OF
A WONDERFUL REPORT.
ON THAT I THINK ARE ARE WORTH
EMPHASIZING TO ONE IS REALLY
SUPPORT THIS FOCUS ON TARGETED
UNIVERSALISM AND THINKING ABOUT
BOTH THIS LONG TERM UNIVERSAL
GOAL OF ENSURING THAT EVERY
CHILD -- AND
FAMILY HAS ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL --
BUT THEN STARTING WITH THOSE WHO
WE KNOW COULD BENEFIT MOST IN
NEED IT MOST --
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ARE IN
POVERTY WHO ARE FACING OTHER
CHALLENGES I'M IN MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE --
THOSE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW WE'RE
GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THOSE DISPARITIES --
IN LANGUAGE AND LITERACY AND
SOCIAL SKILLS START AS EARLY AS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS ON SO WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THEM.
AND SECOND THIS REALLY --
SIGNIFICANT FOCUS ON THE C. WORK
FORCE -- AND
RECOGNIZING ESPECIALLY THAT WE
GEN -- FOR
EASY TEACHERS AND WORKFORCE AT
ITS EQUIVALENT --
TO THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM --
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY ENSURE
THAT OUR KIDS HAVE THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
THANK YOU.
HI MELISSA CAN WITH CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES WE WORK ON
INCREASING ACCESS TO FOOD FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AND CHILDCARE MEALS ARE IN OFTEN
UNRECOGNIZED BUT REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
ANY CHILD EXPERIENCING CHILD
CARE AS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMISSION FOR INCLUDING WITH
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPLEMENT
THE COST OF THREE MEALS AND
CHILD CARE I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY --
BUT IN PARTICULAR KEVIN MCCARTY --
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND CHAMPION
THOUGHT THAT REQUEST LAST YEAR
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WE HOPE
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
MOVE ALONG AGAIN THIS YEAR --
WHEN WE DON'T THE SUPPLEMENT THE
CHILD CARE OF REIMBURSEMENT FOR
A CHILD CARE MEALS UNFORTUNATELY
LOW INCOME PROVIDERS HAVE TO CUT
INTO THEIR ALREADY LIMITED
BUDGETS TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
AND SO IT JUST HURTS OUR?
OUR ATTEMPTS TO IMPROVE THE ACT
THE FUNDING FOR CHILDCARE AS A
WHOLE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI DENNIE MICHELETTI COLBERN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION I TO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMISSION AND STAFF I HAVE
TO SAY --
I'VE BEEN IN THIS FIELD MANY
YEARS AND IT IS REALLY NICE TO
SEE A REPORT.
THAT REFLECTS THE FULL SYSTEM
AND WHEN I MEAN THAT.
WE GO TO SO MANY OF THESE WORK
GROUPS AND WE TALK ABOUT A REAL
INCLUSIVE EARLY LEARNING SYSTEM.
BUT WE FORGET THAT THE RULES FOR
THIS --
DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER PART OF
THE FEEL.
AND THIS REALLY ADDRESS BOTH AND
I HAVE TO COMMEND AND THANK YOU --
I AM LINE A LOT OF WITH A LOT OF
THE COMMENTS I WANT TO CALL OUT
A COUPLE THINGS FROM THE REPORT
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
ESTABLISHED LATE ESTABLISHING
THE FAMILY IN CRISIS.
I MEAN.
OUR AGENCIES ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE WHEN FAMILIES NEED
CHILDCARE THEY DON'T NEED IT
TOMORROW THEY NEEDED AN HOUR
FROM NOW IS THE POLICE TO BE
TAKEN AWAY THESE KIDS.
THEY NEED SOMEPLACE SAFE WE
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON ALIGNING
AND STREAMLINING THE PROGRAM
WITH THE DESIRED OUTCOME TO
MAXIMIZE THE FUNDING AND GET AS
MANY LITTLE PEOPLE IN SPACES AS
POSSIBLE.
HOPEFULLY WITH THE DESIRED
OUTCOME OF NOT RETURNING ONE
SINGLE DOLLAR.
EVERY YEAR --
WE RECOGNIZE AND WE THANK THE
NEED TO HAVE A DISASTER RECOVERY
PLAN WE'VE SEEN IN CINEMA AND IN
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY WHERE THAT WAS</c>
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
IT IS STILL HAPPENING IN THE
PATCHWORK WAY WITHOUT ANY
COORDINATED PLAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY PLANNING COULD
DELIVER HOW WHAT WE NEED WE
VALUE THAT THERE WAS RECOGNITION
OF THE FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR --
WITH PAY WE ALSO VALUE THE B.
WORD THAT WE DON'T HEAR VERY
OFTEN WHICH IS BENEFITS.
PAY AND BENEFITS TO PROVIDERS IS
HUGE AND MAKING SURE WOULD BUILD
THE SYSTEM UP.
WITH LIFTING ALL BOATS THAT STAY
OUT STARTING WITH FAMILY FRIEND
AND NEIGHBOR.
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE BUILDING
ON THE EXISTING MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM -- WE
APPRECIATE MOVING THEN IN AN
COMPLIANCE AND DISTRUST. TO
WELCOME MEAN ALL FAMILIES AND
LIFTING KIDS ACT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OKAY MERRY BREEDING I AM HERE
FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING SEQUEL.
AND I'VE BEEN A PROVIDER FOR
OVER THIRTY ONE YEARS.
SO I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF NOW
HAVING HAD GRAHAM BOND.
THE SUN IN NOW BABY IN MY CARE
SO -- WE
BELIEVE NOT ONLY IN CONTINUITY
OF CARE BUT LONG TO TO HIT --
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMISSION
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE REPORT AND
SEQUEL SUPPORTS AND ALIGNS WITH.
99% IT'S I THINK IT'S BEEN.
REALLY WONDERFUL TO SEE HOW
COMPREHENSIVE AND INCLUSIVE THE
REPORT HAS BEEN.
BUT SEQUEL IS ALSO THE LARGEST
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS REACHING OVER NINE
THOUSAND PROVIDERS.
AND WE ASK THAT --
SEQUEL BE PART OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL PRIVATE
PROVIDERS PROVIDE BETWEEN
SEVENTY AND 80% OF THE CARE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ASKED TO BE AT THE TABLE --
WE ALSO ASK FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPLY FOR AND CONTINUE TO
APPLYING FOR DIRECT CONTRACTS --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION OR AS THESE CONTRACTS
COME UP TO PROVIDE EARLY
EDUCATION.
AS ONE OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
SAID.
WE DON'T CONTRACT OUT SIX GREAT
WHY WOULD WE CONTRACT OUT.
OPRY K. R. T. K. [inaudible]
I THE OTHER COMMENTS I HAVE A
MORE AS A PROVIDER.
SO THE AVERAGE WAITING TIME FOR
A PERMIT FAR TEACHERS RIGHT NOW
IS SIX MONTHS.
WE HAVE --
STAFF WHO COME TO US QUALIFIED.
THEY HAVE THEIR BACHELOR'S BUT
THEN YOU HAVE TO GO APPLY FOR
THIS PERMIT AND BECAUSE OF THE
WORK LOG IT TAKES ABOUT SIX
MONTHS FOR THAT PERSON. TO BE
ABLE -- TO
BE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU CAN YOU WRAP UP PLEASE.
YES -- AND
THE OTHER PART I WANTED TO ALSO
SAY WE APPRECIATE.
THE RISK RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
STAFF QUALITY OF LIFE AND
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES BUT IF WE COULD
ALSO LOOK AT A SYSTEM FOR
SUBSTITUTES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M WE ARE
VERY THANKFUL TO BE PART OF THIS
UNIQUE TEAM.
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND FOR OUR FUTURE
FAMILIES HELLO MY NAME IS
CELESTE GLENDALE AND I HAVE BEEN
A FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN
TULARE COUNTY. FOR OVER TWENTY
FOUR YEARS I AM JOINED HERE WITH
MY FELLOW AS HE I YOU.
FIVE TO ONE LOCAL FIVE TWO ONE
PROVIDERS WHO CARE FOR IN
EDUCATE CHILDREN IN THE BAY AREA
SILICON AND CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION FOR LEADING US
ON THIS ISSUE AND GIVING AS THE
SPACE TO PROVIDE OUR INPUT HERE
TODAY.
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INCLUDING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN SECTION.
FOUR OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
CAN'T BEGIN TO EXPRESS WHAT IT
MEANS TO US PROVIDERS.
STANDING HERE TODAY WHO HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR THIS RIGHT FOR
OVER A DECADE.
WE ARE ALSO HERE TODAY BECAUSE
WHILE WE AGREED WITH WHAT YOU
HAVE LAID OUT AND SECTION.
THREE RELATING TO ACCESS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE MUST GO BIGGER.
AND STRIVEFOR A SYSTEM THAT
TRULY PROVIDES CHILDCARE FOR ALL.
IF ANYONE CAN LEAD.
THE WAY IN THIS IT'S CALIFORNIA.
THEREFORE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL REPORT.
THEREFORE WE STAND HERE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
LONG AS IT TAKES.
SURE FOR EVERY CHILD. TO BE SURE
THAT EVERY CHILD EVERY CHILD HAS
ACCESS TO THE CHILD CARE THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FORCING.
HI MY NAME IS SALLY C. AT TURNER.
I AM BEING WORKING AS A CHILD
CARE PROVIDED FOR NINE YEARS AND
FINANCIAL STUDY ALLOWS --
I'M HERE WITH MY FEET LOS --
YOU THE W. PROVIDERS WILL CARE
FOR IN IT OKAY CHILDREN'S IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO.
MISSION THERE THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
COMPELLING ALL THESE --
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I MUST SAY THAT WE WERE PREPARED
TO COME HERE WOULD WHY YOU SHALL
INCLUDE.
AT THE MARKETING.
BUT THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
BUT YOU GUYS ALREADY HAVE DONE.
A GREAT JOB SO THANK YOU.
BYE INCLUDING ON SECTION FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE DOCUMENT.
OUT WE WOULD PREFER TO COME HERE
AND TELL YOU HOW HARD WORK IS BY
PREPARING.
WE PLAY SO MANY ROLES DURING
THAT THEY PREPARING BREAKFAST
LUNCH DINNER IBM IS NOT A AND
WAS NOT.
WE TEACH THE KIDS WE PREPARE UP
RICH ENVIRONMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE KIDS GHOST PREPARE
OUR PREPARE FOR KINDERGARTEN --
WE HAVE TO DROP KIDS AT SCHOOL
WE HAVE TO PICK UP GETS A SCHOOL.
WE WERE PREPARED TO TELL YOU HOW
HARD IT IS TO PROVIDE FOR OUR
FAMILY BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
LICENSEE ONCE WE HAVE THE SEVEN
KIDS WE HAVE TO HIRE THE SECOND
ASSISTANCE SO WE CAN GO INTO UP
THOSE KIDS AND PICK UP THOSE
KIDS AND PROVIDE A SERVICE FOR
THE PARENTS.
THAT THEY NEED TO CONTINUE
WORKING --
BUT INSTEAD I'M GONNA TELL YOU
THANK YOU.
WE CAN TELL YOU HOW --
EMPOWER WE FEEL ALL TO THE I
WENT BECAUSE WE SPOKE UP AND YOU
HARRIS.
THANK YOU TOOK ACTIONS.
WE KNOW THAT OUR FIGHT TO WIN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS ARE
AFRAID TO GIVE EVERY CHILD
IMPAIRING THE AXIS THEY NEED IS
NOT OVER.
BUT TODAY WE FELT HURT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS THE MEASURE GRIFFIN I
HAVE BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN APPLE VALLEY AREA
FOR OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS.
I'M JOINED HERE BY MY FELLOW AT
THE IDEA ON LOCAL NINETY NINE
PROVIDERS.
WHO CARE FOR AND EDUCATE
CHILDREN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA?
I LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING YOU
THE COMMISSION FOR LISTENING TO
EVERY SINGLE FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER WHO HAS PARTICIPATED IN
THESE HEARINGS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
BY INCLUDING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN SECTION.
FOUR OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS WAY
YOU HAVE ALSO HEARD FROM AS MANY
OF YOU HAVE ECHOED IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
CAN'T KEEP RUNNING AS IT DOES
NOW THE HIGH COST OF CARE LACK
OF ACCESS AND POOR PAY FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS.
MEANS OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WE HAVE ALSO HEARD WARY FROM
MANY AS TO HOW WE ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR ALL OF THIS.
SO WE ARE HERE TO ASK YOU.
THAT AS YOU FINALIZE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM
IN SECTION NINE THANK YOU
INCLUDE A MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVE
PATH. FOR HOW WE ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR ALL OF THIS IN THAT
PATHWAY IS TWO PRONGED.
FIRST WE MUST MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
CORPORATIONS PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE AS A RESULT OF THE TRUMP
TAX CUTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA'S FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES PROP IS BLOWN
BY NEARLY FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER WHAT THEY AREN'T IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR AN AWFUL LOT
OF MANY.
THOSE CORPORATIONS BENEFIT
TREMENDOUSLY FROM CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD CARE SYSTEM AND MANY HAVE
EMPLOYEES WHO DON'T FOR WHO EARN
SO LITTLE THAT THEY QUALIFY FOR
SUBSIDIES THEY SHOULD PAY.
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
THANK IN CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR BILLION
YEARS WHO HAVE MORE THAN TRIPLED
THEIR WEALTH AND THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND NOW HAVE A COLLECT THE
NETWORK OF OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS.
DAY NOT ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM
SHOULD AND MUST PAY TO FULLY
FUND THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MARCELLA GRAVES I'M A
CHALK PROVIDER FRESNO CALIFORNIA
FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS WITH THE
RIGHT NOW WITH SEIU LOCAL FIVE
TWO ONE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMISSION FOR INVESTING IN ALL
SUBSIDIZED CARE.
AND EQUAL PAY FAIR AND
AFFORDABLE CARE ACROSS THE BOARD
I GET CALLS FROM PARENTS LOOKING
FOR PROGRAMS FOR CHILDCARE FOR
FREE OR REDUCED AND FREE
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM
SCHOOL.
I'M ALWAYS HAVING TO SAY SORRY I
DON'T THERE'S NO PROGRAMS AT
THIS TIME.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
COMMISSION FOR INCLUDING
UNIVERSAL GOAL FOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THE CHILDREN.
AND AND IN OUR PRIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOD BLESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER CRAPPIE
WITH PERRIN PLACES CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS TRULY.
A REMARKABLE DAY.
WHEN I LOOK AROUND IN THIS ROOM
AND I I HEAR AND I SEE ALL OF
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS?
PARENTS AND ADVOCATES.
I FEEL THIS.
SENSE OF PRIDE.
PRIDE KNOWING THAT WE ARE ALL
HERE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
PARTNERSHIP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS REPORT BECOMES REALITY.
WE ARE HERE.
ON THIS DAY BUT WE WILL BE HERE
EVERY.
EVERY DAY IN IN IN DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT.
EACH ONE OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS CALMS --
ACTUALLY TO LIGHT.
BUT THAT THE PARENTS CAN
ACTUALLY GOAL AND ACCESS THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED.
THAT IN A COUPLE OF YEARS FROM
NOW WE WON'T BE SAYING THAT WE
HAVE A WAITING LIST OF ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION KIDS.
IN A COUPLE OF YEARS WILL BE
SAYING THAT OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE PAID A LIVING WAGE.
AND EVEN MORE.
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE THAT.
IN A COUPLE OF YEARS WE WON'T
HAVE TO LOOK AT PARENTS AND SAY.
I'M SO SORRY BUT THERE'S NO HELP
FOR YOU.
AND WITH PARTNERSHIP OF ALL OF
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
AND ALL OF THE MEMBERS SITTING --
ON THE DíAS TODAY.
WE ARE HERE TO HELP AND TO
SUPPORT BUT ALSO TO HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE.
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKING SURE THAT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS DON'T JUST
SIT ON A SHELF.
BUT THEY ACTUALLY BECOME REALITY
BECAUSE THE CHILDREN FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA DESERVE IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON K<c.cyan> MILLER</c>
WITH CHILDREN NOW.
AND JUST EXPRESSING OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR EFFORTS --
AND THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT
THIS REPORT --
COVERED AND I WE REALLY FEEL
LIKE IT'S GOING TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION TO SOLUTIONS
CONVERSATION VERSES JUST --
A REPORT THAT'S GOING TO BE AND
THAT WE ALL KNOW WE WANT --
WE ARE PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO
SEE THAT KNOWLEDGE MINT AND THE
NEED -- FOR
DATA AND DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS --
AND SOME EXAMPLES OF INITIAL
STEPS IN THEIR THE CHILD
IDENTIFIER PARTICIPATION IN THE
WORK FORCE REGISTRY BUILDING UP
THE CONSUMER EDUCATION DATABASE --
WITH THE WORK FORCE AND QUALITY
RECOMMENDATIONS --
THE FOCUS ON RAISING RATES --
TO SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT
COMPENSATION AND ON GOING IN
QUALITY --
IMPROVEMENT WAS CRITICAL AND WE
WOULD SAY THE WORK OF CLARIFYING
IN A LINE ALIGNING AND EVEN IN
SOME CASES ADVANCING WORKFORCE
QUALIFICATIONS --
AND EXPECTATIONS AND TEARS OF
QUALITY COULD BE DONE AT THE
SAME TIME --
AND IS IN FACT ALSO A CRITICAL
PIECE OF STRENGTHENING THE
SYSTEM.
AND THEN WE ALSO WANTED TO OF
COURSE APPLAUD AGENCY CHILD CARE
I AM FOR FASTER CHOI GRAHAM AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THERE --
AND WE REALLY WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF FOSTER
CHILDREN AND HOW THEY'RE BEING
SERVED THROUGH THE BRIDGE --
IS PRESERVED AND EXPANDED AND
THAT'S WHAT CHILDREN NOW AN
ARRAY OF PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS ARE --
IN REQUESTING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET EXPANSION OF THAT PROGRAM.
AND THEN MY FINAL COME IT WOULD
JUST BE BASED ON ALL YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR YEARS OF WORK.
LAST TWO YEARS OF WORK AND
PERHAPS THIS IS COMING BUT SOME
WAY TO ARTICULATE YOUR SENSE ON
TIME LINES AND HOW THINGS COULD
ADVANCE WHAT STEPS YOU GO FIRST
WHAT SHOULD WE FOCUS ON IN THE
NEXT YOU KNOW YEAR.
TWO THREE ALL THE WAY OUT TO THE
TEN YEAR MARK JUST GIVEN ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE I THINK THAT
COULD BE REALLY HELPFUL AS WELL
AS ARTICULATING SORT OF THE THE
HOW AND THE WHO.
YOU KNOW IS IT LEGISLATIVE IT IS
IT IS IT ADMINISTRATIVE IS AN
AGENCY THAT NEEDS TO START THESE
THINGS -- SO
WE JUST APPRECIATE GIVEN ALL
YOUR HARD WORK THAT IF THERE'S
SOME WAY TO CAPTURE THAT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VALERIE DINERO AND I'M WITH
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA FORMALLY
SEE CDA AND I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW HOW MUCH --
I FEEL SO EXCITED AS SOMEONE HAS
BEEN IN THE FIELD FOR TWENTY
PLUS YEARS IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION TO SEE THE ROBUST WORK.
THE COMPREHENSIVE A VISION THAT
ALL OF YOU HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER
AS A COLLABORATIVE I HEAR THE
VOICES OF OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AT THE TABLE.
OUR REGION EXCELL EVERY SYSTEM
THE RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED FOR
OUR WORK FORCE TO ENHANCE IT TO
MAKE IT.
BE WHAT WE KNOW CALIFORNIA NEEDS
IT TO I ALSO APPLIED MY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR NINA BUSSEY
WHO SITS ON THE BLUE CRITIC
COMMISSION AND IS IN WASHINGTON
DC TODAY --
CONTINUING THE MISSION IN THE
FIGHT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ITS SO EXCITING TO NOT SIT
HERE AND TALK ABOUT THE WHAT WE
NEED AND WHAT IS WRONG WE ARE SO
EXCITED TO BE HERE AS A PARTNER
WITH ALL OF YOU.
IN ESTABLISHING THE HOUSE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS A REALITY
FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE OCCUR
GONNA ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
ON YOUR WHOLE CHILD AND FAMILY
CENTERED APPROACH TO LAY OUT A
LONG TERM HOLISTIC VISION FOR A
HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS EVERY
STATE'S YOUNGEST CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
WELL WE ARE STILL GOING THROUGH
THE THOUGHTFUL AND COMPREHENSIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN YOUR DRAFT
REPORT WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
FEW HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS.
FIRST WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE PROPOSAL TO
REFORM THE STATE'S EAZY E.
REIMBURSEMENT RATES SYSTEM.
THIS IS A CRUCIAL POLICY THAT WE
NEED TO ADOPT THIS YEAR BECAUSE
IT WILL TAKE A FEW YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT.
WE'RE ALSO PLEASED TO SEE THE
INCLUSION OF EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND INTERVENTION
THIS IS A CRITICAL SYSTEM THAT
NEEDS SIGNIFICANT ATTENTION TO
HELP OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE COVERING THE
IMPORTANT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
SYSTEM AND THE NEED FOR ALL
PROVIDERS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS REPORT
WE WILL BE SUBMITTING WRITTEN
COMMENTS WITH MORE SPECIFIC
FEEDBACK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SUSAN BONY I'M
WITH COUNSEL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA REPRESENTING BUSINESS
LEADERS MILITARY LEADERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
REPORT TODAY --
WE DID A NATIONAL STUDY THAT
**** DEMONSTRATED THAT THE COST
OF ARE INADEQUATE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM ACROSS THIS NATION IS A
FIFTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR COST.
THAT COST IS ASSIGNED IN LOST
WAGES TO WORKERS AND THAT'S
ROUGHLY THIRTY SEVEN BILLION TO
BUSINESSES THEY LOSE THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN LOST
PRODUCTIVITY AND HAVING TO RE
TRAIN.
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
BECAUSE OF THE CHILD CARE CRISIS
AND THEN WE LOSE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS NATIONALLY IN TAXES.
BECAUSE OUR WORKERS AREN'T ABLE
TO WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT --
REPRESENTING READY NATION ARE
BUSINESS LEADERS --
AND OTHER SECTORS THAT WE STAND
READY SHOULDER AND SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER WITH YOU TO HELP SOLVE
THIS CRISIS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IT'S ONE THAT WHEN WE ALL COME
TOGETHER AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST A MONEY COST IT'S
A PUBLIC SAFETY COST IT'S A
NATIONAL SECURITY COSTS AND IT'S
AN ECONOMIC LOSS TO TO OUR
NATION AND TO THE FUTURE OF
THESE CHILDREN SO WE STAND READY
TO SERVE WITH YOU. TO COME UP
WITH THESE SOLUTIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE HARD WORK YOU'VE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS REPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO -- MY
NAME'S OSCAR I'M FROM SAN OSKAR
TANG -- WE
HUNG TEN I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND AND I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DEATH AND THE CHILD CARE
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
TH<c.cyan> CARE NETWORK.</c>
SOUL --
TODAY IS MY FIRST TIME ATTENDING
THERE ARE --
BROUGH WE'VE THEN AND THEN I
WANT TO YEAH I I THINK THAT WE
PUT YOU SWEETIE FALL ROTH AND
AND YEAH EIGHTY FOUR PAGES TO
OFFICE --
DEFINITELY A LOT TALK PAGES FOR
US TO GOAL FOOL --
WILL WANT THE TODAY I'M COMING --
FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
I WANT TO SHARE SOME TAUGHT AND
ABOUT --
DEAF AND A CHILD CARE --
IT YOU ALREADY KNOW ON THIRTIES
TENS TEENAGERS AWFUL BUT IT'S
GOOD THAT I SEE IS ON FACEBOOK --
ALREADY FEET --
YET FEEDING DAYS AND THEN I'LL
BE OUT WE ARE SAYING THIS ALL
WITH THEIR POLITE THEIR TESTS
ARE NOT ABLE TO COME OVER --
BUT THEY DO HAVE --
EITHER CHALLENGE --
SOUL I WANT TO ON THE FENCE --
OUR PARTNER ON HEALTHCARE LAW
CENTER --
BECAUSE THOUGHT THEY DO WILL
HELP US TO ON UNDERSTAND APART
SAYS SAW ALL ON DIFFERENT DEAL
BILLS THAT'S AFFECTING THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE FEEL.
AND WILL BUT THERE SALAS TOOL
CHALLENGE BECAUSE FOR US THAT'S
NOT FINISHED OKAY APPLY THERE --
SOMETIME AND UP TO THE LONG
HOURS AND THEN FOR THEIR YEAH
LÏNG.
YET THERE ARE LANGUAGE --
TON STATION PARTS SO THEY'RE A
SPANISH BELIE THEIR CHINESE
BELIE THE RUSSIAN COLLIDE THERE --
TALK ALL APPLY THERE --
CAN BE INCLUDED IN THE PARSIS
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIME ON THE
YEAH THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT --
ODDITIES ARE WHAT YOU'VE
HAPPENING ON A DAY TO KNOW ABOUT
WHAT IS ALREADY AT EXCAVATION
ALREADY AND THEN IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR THEM.
STILL FOR US TO CHANGE THINGS
ONCE THINGS NOT WRITTEN IN THE
LEGISLATIVE FUND --
YEAH I'M NOT IMMIGRANT TO AND
THEN I DON'T KNOW THE SYSTEM ALL
YOU NEED TO DO IT DAYS TO DO
THAT AND SO IT IS REALLY HARD TO
HOLD PLUSES WE NEED TO ALL --
BEING MORE IN COURSES --
YEAH WELL IF YOU WANT TO DO IT
IN -- TO
TAKE CARE TO IN PLEASE THAT
BUYERS AND ALL THOSE THINGS --
YES SOMETIME AND WE WE WE WE NOT
WHILE WE WILL HAVE TO TRY THIS
AND FAITH ON ALL THE PEOPLE HERE
AND THEN --
WHAT THEY'RE DOING?
WRAPPING UP PLEASE --
AND ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO A POINT
HOW.
SO RIGHT NOW IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
HAVE THERE I SEE PET MEETING
TALKING ABOUT THEIR I'LL
INCREASING WAGES AND
COMPENSATION ALL DAY THING.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THERE'S NOT
IT'S NOT --
JUST INCREASING THE WAGES
BECAUSE WHEN YOU INCREASE THE
WAGES THEY WILL --
MAKE THAT BENEFIT --
THEY ARE ALL AND MAYBE HOSTING --
HOUSING ISSUE --
HEALTHCARE --
BENEFIT THEY THEY MAY GET OFF TO
SELL A YEAH I'M ALL FUNDING FOR
THE LOCAL I. SO STATION BECAUSE
A LOT OF LOCAL FENDER TELECASTER
WAS STATION IT'S ALREADY.
CLOSED DOWN BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING DOWN ONE
TEAR BASE AND THEN --
ITS MEMBERSHIP BASED ONLY SOUL
THANK YOU.
YEAH I THINK OF IN THE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
FABULOUS PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
AND I KNOW THIS IS OUR FINAL
HEARING BUT WE'RE NOT DONE SO I
JUST WANT TO GIVE.
A FEW --
PARTY COMMENTS SO FIRST I
THOUGHT IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
BUT WHEN I THINK.
OUR TEAM WHO PUT THIS TOGETHER
NANCY AND GAIL AND STACY I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR IT'S VERY
COMPREHENSIVE OF COURSE OUR PLAN
HERE.
AND WE COULD HAVE NEVER --
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS --
YOU KNOW TWO YEARS AGO GET ALONG
TEN YEARS AGO BUT WE CAN BUILD
UPON IT AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
TELLING THE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
ARE LISTENING IN HERE TODAY WE
HAVE UNTIL MARCH TWENTIETH TO
SUBMIT ANY.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
ABOUT KING THERE WERE A FEW GOOD
QUESTIONS I WANT TO ADDRESS A
SOMEBODY ASKED ABOUT --
SEQUENCING AND COSTS AND REVENUE
OPTIONS AND SO YOU KNOW THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS HOW YOU
WOULD PAY FOR THIS AND HOW MUCH
IT WOULD COST OF COURSE SO.
OUR FINAL --
PRODUCT WHICH IS GOING TO COME
OUT IN LATE APRIL JUST LET
PEOPLE KNOW LATE APRIL WILL
PROBABLY NOT HAVE A HEARING BUT
HAVE ANY EVENT AN UNVEILING OF
THIS FINAL REPORT.
WELL WILL LAY OUTS --
SHORT TERM MID TERM AND LONG
TERM A SEQUENCING OF THIS FOR
THE OUT YEARS A COUPLE YEARS YOU
KNOW THREE TO FIVE YEARS AND UP
TO TEN YEARS.
A LOSS OF COURSE LAY OUT OF THE
COST ESTIMATES FOR FOR DOING
THIS AS WELL AS LOOKING AT SOME
REVENUE OPTIONS HOW WE CAN --
PAY FOR CERTAINLY WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WE CAN'T OF THE STATE
BUDGET THE WE REALIZE THERE ARE.
LIMITATIONS BASED UPON OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES AS WELL AS THE
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE --
SO -- SO
WITH THAT --
WE WILL --
FINALIZE THIS IN THE NEXT MY
STATION THIS FABULOUS PROCESS
INCLUDING.
ALL OF OUR COMMISSIONERS AND ANY --
PARTING COMMENTS FROM OUR FROM
OUR COMMISSIONERS.-OKAY.
PASSING NOT.
IS HE HAS YEAH COMING INTO THE
BUILDING --
SEVERAL OF US I HEARD THIS
AMAZING --
GROUP OF VOICES CHANTING.
AND THEY WERE REALLY ENERGETIC.
THEY WERE VERY YOUNG TO THEY
WERE COLLEGE KIDS.
AND THEY WERE CHANTING WHAT DO
WE WHAT WE WANT.
FINANCIAL AID.
WHEN WE WANT IT NOW?
IN THIS SENSE IS SOME OF THOSE
ORGANS THAT WOULD ONLY WANT
FINANCIAL AID.
WE WANTED FOR OUR LITTLE ONES SO
THAT THEY CAN GET TO COLLEGE BUT
I THINK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
YEAH SO THAT WAS A VERY
ENERGETIC YES.
THAT WAS BURKE --
COLLEGE FINANCIAL FINANCIAL WAY
WHEN IT WENT TO THE CHANCE.
YOU DO IT YOU GOT.
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
COME ON WHAT ARE WE WANT.
WHEN WE WANTED [inaudible] FOR
EASY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK THAT WOULD THAT
WILL CONCLUDE RICHARD